hey everyone welcome to this react js
crash course react is a javascript
library used to create fancy user
interfaces for mobile and desktop
applications it is widely used and is
preferred over other frameworks for
front-end development
so if you wish to learn web development
then you're in the right place
this video covers all the necessary
topics to give you a good understanding
of react and some of its basic concepts
so here's a list of things we're going
to be covering in the video
first we'll begin with a quick
introduction to react then we'll move
ahead with react installation on windows
later we'll cover topics like react
components props and state
next we're going to build an application
from scratch
after that we'll have a look at
different javascript frameworks like
react angular and view
we're also going to be covering topics
like connecting react.js with node.js
react with redux
and we'll see the comparison between
react native and flutter
and after this we'll end this extensive
session with some interview questions
all of this under 4.5 hours
so let's begin
in today's video we'll be learning all
about react.js so let's jump in and see
what's in store for us so we'll be
covering topics on what is react why
react features of react react
prerequisites and its industry trends
let's go ahead and begin with what is
react react is a javascript library used
to build fast and interactive user
interfaces for both web and mobile
applications now one thing that makes
react extremely powerful is the fact
that it's open source any user can
access its source code modify it and
enhance it in a typical model view
controller architecture react defines
the view part of the application it is
also responsible for how the app looks
and feels fun fact react was built by
jordan walkey an engineer at facebook
now let's go ahead and see how react
works in real time consider a typical
web application say instagram the entire
ui of the web page is divided into
several components we have the search
component a profile description
component stories component and a post
list component these components make the
code easier to debug and always remain
discrete components also make
development and maintenance of web
applications faster as multiple
developers can work simultaneously on
different components of the same web
application now let's see why react is
so popular these days the act helps in
creation of dynamic web applications it
also provides performance enhancements
now there are several performance
enhancements like virtual dom and
one-way data binding we'll learn about
these topics a little later in the video
react uses reusable components now this
helps decrease the development time
react involves unidirectional flow of
data react also has a small learning
curve compared to other frameworks like
angular react is much easier to learn
react can also be used for mobile
applications react recently released an
extension called react native that is
used for developing mobile applications
that are cross-compatible it also has
dedicated tools for easy debugging now
let's dive in to the features of react
first let's understand jsx jsx is a
syntax extension to javascript using jsx
we can add html to the javascript file
all coding in react is done using jsx it
also helps in making the code easier to
understand and debug ultimately jsx is a
combination of javascript and html now
let's consider a small example cons
simple here is a javascript notation h1
tags indicate html again the semicolon
indicates javascript note that the
semicolon is not mandatory however it's
a good practice to include it moving on
the next feature is virtual dom dom
which is an acronym for data object
model actually defines how documents are
accessed and manipulated in a web page
it represents the entire structure of
the web page in the form of a tree
now let's see how this actually works
react creates a virtual dom that is the
exact copy of the real dom traditionally
whenever something changes in the web
application all objects in the real dom
are updated this makes it extremely slow
let's see how react counters this now
consider two objects whose states have
been changed react now compares the
virtual dom with the virtual dom
snapshot that was taken right before the
update by comparing the new virtual dom
with the pre-update version react
figures out exactly which virtual dom
objects have changed now react only
updates those objects on the virtual dom
this makes a big difference when it
comes to speed coming to the next
feature performance react uses virtual
dom as discussed earlier virtual dog
impacts the speed of the web
applications we also took an example of
instagram and learned how multiple
components can affect the development
time they help improve performance
drastically the next feature is one way
data binding this means information
flows in only one direction one way data
binding is specifically used when
information is displayed and not updated
remember that the components of react
are functional in nature that is they
receive information through arguments
and pass information via their return
values the next important feature is
extensions react has many extensions
that we can use to create full-fledged
front-end applications it provides
server-side rendering which means that
the application is rendered on the
server rather than in the browser react
native which is a react extension is
used for developing mobile applications
there are many other extensions that
react provides for every scenario in web
development now let's look at a few of
them react native lets you build mobile
applications using only javascript a
react native app is a real mobile
application and not just a web
application running on your mobile
devices thousands of applications like
facebook instagram pinterest skype use
react native the next popular react
extension is flux flux is the
application architecture that facebook
uses flux implements a unidirectional
flow which makes it easier to understand
what actually is going on now let's see
how it works when we trigger an action
the dispatcher will get notified the
dispatcher receives actions and
dispatches them to the stores a store is
what holds the data of an application
stores will register with the
application's dispatcher so that they
can receive actions data from stores is
displayed in views actions define the
internal api of your application they
capture how anything might interact with
your application the last feature of
react is debugging react applications
are easy to debug thanks to the large
and active developer community you can
practically debug react codes within
your browser now notice the small react
extension icon at the top right corner
this developer tool allows the user to
inspect the code and also easily debug
it moving on let's learn about the
building blocks of react components
state and props are the essential
concepts that one should know before
implementing react they are the
foundation on which react is built now
what exactly are react components
components are the building blocks of
any react application react divides the
user interface into multiple components
wherein each component defines how a
particular element is viewed in the
application react components remain
discrete and are processed independently
another feature is reusability
components can be reused multiple times
across the application this reduces the
development time consider the following
code snippet a component is implemented
as a javascript class having some state
and a render method state is the data
which we want the component to render
the render method is responsible for how
the ui looks and feels to the user the
next concept is state state of a
component is an object that holds some
data this data influences the output of
a component every time the state of an
object changes the component is
re-rendered onto the screen now let's
see what props are props or short for
properties allow us to pass arguments or
data to components properties help make
components more dynamic it is important
to define all the properties their types
and their default value props are passed
to components in a way similar to that
of html tag attributes now consider the
following code snippets this shows
exactly how properties are passed to
components also detailed illustrations
on components props and state will be
shown in the upcoming videos so stay
tuned for that moving on let's go
through some of the things that you
should know before you can actually
start working on react you should be
familiar with programming concepts like
functions objects arrays and classes one
should also have a basic knowledge of
javascript and a familiarity with html
don't worry if you feel like you're not
good at them once you start working on
them you'll get a good hang of it
finally let's go through the impact of
react on the it industry and get
insights into the salaries of react
developers statistics show that react
developers earn way more than other web
developers according to pay scale the
average salary for a react developer in
the united states is a whopping 91 000
us dollars the average salary for a
react developer in india is 7.25 lakhs
per annum over the recent years react
has gained immense popularity and is
being adopted by many companies
according to the data by google trends
react has had a better growth scale
compared to other frameworks like
angular and vue statistics show that
front-end developers have wholeheartedly
adopted this lightweight framework
foregoing other available options if you
are skilled and have a knack for
front-end development react can help you
gain fantastic career opportunities
lastly talking about a few companies
that use react devotionally we have
facebook instagram netflix dropbox
whatsapp among others in today's video
we'll be learning all about react
installation on windows so without
further ado let's get started to set up
the react development environment we
need two things installed node and a
text editor of your choice so let's
begin by installing nodejs we can head
to the official node.js website save
download
node.js so here you can see the windows
installer depending on your system you
can either download the 32-bit version
or the 64-bit version so i'm going to go
ahead and click on the 64-bit version
since it's already installed on my
system i'm not again installing node you
can follow the installation guidelines
and download it once you're done with
node installation you can go ahead and
download a text editor of your choice so
i'd suggest vs code so let's head to the
vs code page say download vs code click
on the first link and download the
64-bit version for windows once you're
done with the installation of both node
and your text editor you can start
creating your first react application so
for that let's create a folder
i'm creating it on my desktop while you
can create it in any of your drives
let's call it first react now open your
command prompt now you can type in the
path for the folder that you just
created so say
cd
users
first react now go ahead and type in the
command npm
install
hyphen g create
react
app okay so this command installs all
the necessary react.js modules now to
check if the version is correctly
installed you can type in create
react app version so you can see the
version here now let's continue and
develop your react application type in
the command create
react app
and you can give a name to your
application so i say my app
now this should take a couple of minutes
okay once you've successfully created
your application
they say to begin by typing the
following commands so let's do that save
cd my app and npm start this should
typically start your application and
here we go
all right you can also open your
application in the text editor that
you've downloaded so let's go ahead and
open vs code vs code file
open folder go to your desktop or the
drive that you've saved your folder in
first react
my app and i say select folder so as you
can see all your modules have been
imported you can click on app.js and
start editing in today's video we'll be
learning all about the most basic
infrastructure of react.js called
components without delay let's begin and
look at what's in store for us so we'll
be touching on topics like what are
components types of components nesting
components higher order in pure
components and a brief description about
component life cycle all right to begin
with what exactly are components
components are the building blocks of a
react application wherein each component
represents a part of the user interface
now to make it more understandable
consider the facebook home page the
entire ui can be broken down into
several elements say we have the
credentials component the sign up
component the image component and the
logo component notice that each
component adds something to how the home
page looks all right reusability is one
of the salient features of react
components one component can be reused
several times across the application and
this improves the development speed
components can also be nested one
component can internally consist of
several other components in its minimal
form a component must define a render
method that specifies how exactly the
application looks and feels a component
can also receive properties from its
parent components also you'll get a
better understanding of all of these
when we start working hands-on so don't
worry so moving on let's look at the
different types of components first we
have the stateless functional components
and then we have the stateful class
components now functional components are
typical javascript functions that return
html now they can be contained in a dot
js or a dot jsx file coming to class
components these are regular es6 classes
however it's mandatory that they contain
a render method that in turn returns
html they can also be contained in dot
jx or a dot jsx file okay then let's go
ahead and build our first react
application using components all right
so i've opened my text editor that is vs
code to build my application also i
suggest you watch the react installation
on windows video to help you get started
the video briefly explains how to
install node and how to start building
your first react application in my case
i've opened a folder called react
component tutorial and here in my source
folder i have app.js now app.js is the
main component that gets rendered to the
dom let me show you that here in
index.js you pass app.js which is a
component that gets rendered to the
react dom so app.js consists of several
other components that can be nested so
as you can see app.js is a functional
component and before moving on let me
get rid of all the unnecessary code so
let me delete all of this
and return
an h1 tag that says hello welcome to
simply let me save it and if you look at
the browser you'll have hello welcome to
simply learn now let's go ahead and
display another message say h1
this
video is about
components let me save it and let me
check the browser it gives you an error
so jsx uses a conventional rule which
states that all html tags have to be
enclosed within a div tag so for example
i say div
and i enclose it so let me save and
check my browser again here you go so
multiple html tags have to be enclosed
within the div tag moving on let's
create a first functional component to
do that i'll first create a folder in my
source folder say components within that
i'll create a file say
functional component dot js all right so
the first thing we have to do is import
react so i say import react from
yeah the general syntax for a functional
component involves the keyword function
and say
functional
component
now you say return an h1 tag or i've
already used h1 tags so i'll say
paragraph and i say
this is
a functional component all right before
explaining to you how these components
are exported and imported let me show
you the general syntax for a class
component so i create another file say
class component dot js i again import
react from react the general notation is
using the class keyword followed by the
name of the class extending from the
base class the act.component so going
ahead i say class class component
extends react dot component now the key
feature of a class component is the
usage of a render method so i say render
within braces i say return a paragraph
tag saying this is
the class component all right so moving
on let's see how these components can be
nested into the main component that is
app.js components can be nested into the
main component using import and export
keywords so as the name suggests export
feature is used to export a particular
file or a module and import is used to
import a particular file or module into
the current existing module so we have
two different types of exports you have
default export and just export or named
export so a default export is used to
export just one object be it a function
a class a variable from the file and
there can only be one default export
profile and when you're importing it you
can specify the address and use the word
import before it so let me show you how
it works let's go back to our editor and
then functional component and here i say
export default and the name of the
functional component that is
functional com so let me save this and
going back to my app.js i say import
name of the functional component that is
functional com from and i pass the path
this components slash functional
component also let me get rid of these
unnecessary
files here now let's define functional
component in our app.js component so
here i say functional com let's compile
it and check our browser here it says
this is a functional component moving on
to my class component it's the same
syntax here as well i say export default
name of my component and in my app.js i
import it
import class comp from
the path and again i'll have to define
it in my return method i save so let me
compile it and check my browser it says
this is the class component one unique
feature of default export is that i can
rename the file while i'm importing it
so for example i can rename it as say
fc and while i'm defining it i'll have
to make sure i use the same naming
conventions so i say fc again and when i
check it it says this is the functional
component there's literally no
difference the next type of export is
the named export or just export so a
named export can be used to export
multiple objects be it functions class
etc from a file now there can be several
named exports from a single file one
hack is that while you're importing it
cannot be renamed so let me show you how
this works okay so let's create another
class in our class component so i'll
just copy paste this
let me give it another name say class
com one and the message that i want to
display is hey i'm another class all
right so when i'm exporting it i don't
want default so let me take it off and
say export here all right in my app.js
while importing it i want to import both
the classes so i'll include them within
curly braces here i say class comp comma
class comp one and then again i define
it here class comp one let's compile it
and run it and here we go here you can
see hey i'm another class so we've
successfully exported both the classes
from the class component and imported it
back in our app.js component one
advantage of using named export is the
fact that i can choose to import the
classes that i want to now say for
example i do not want to import class
component here so let me take it off and
here let me
comment this now let's compile and see
hey am another class the second class
got imported while the first class i was
defined earlier is not imported here all
right so next up we have higher order
and pure competence now i won't get into
the nativities of it because they're
advanced topics but to give you a brief
insight higher order components are
basically functions that take in a
component and return a new component the
whole ideology behind higher order
components is to facilitate the
reusability of component logic okay so
let's see how this works let's go back
to our code editor let's create a
component in our components folder let's
call the component
click
dot js all right so here we define a
class i use this benefit rce here we go
we get the entire format using the small
snippet rce and here i'm going to make
use of a button now see i use the tag
button and i'll say
clicked
one time every time the user clicks on
the button the value gets incremented so
for this i'm going to use a variable say
count and i'm going to use the concept
of states so let's go ahead and define
our variable count and initialize it to
zero so for that i'm going to use
another snippet called r const and here
this dot state equals my variable count
initializing it to zero so let's define
the count variable in a render method so
i say const count equals this dot state
so every time we click on the button the
count value has to get incremented right
so we make use of an event called on
click equals
this dot
update click
now update click is going to be another
method that we have to define now so
every time the button gets clicked this
method is called so let's go ahead and
define the function so it is update
click equals is going to be an arrow
function and i say
this dot set state is nothing but count
this dot
state dot account plus one okay and here
we say
count times all right so once this is
done let's import our component in
app.js so here again
i say import click from components click
and let's define it here so let's check
our browser every time we click on the
button the value gets incremented all
right so let's go ahead and create
another component say counter.js wherein
every time the user hovers the mouse on
the button the count value increases so
let's go ahead and do that i say
counter dot js i'm again going to use
the snippet rce to create a class
component and here in my div tag i
define a button and say incremented
to for now i say x so now let's go ahead
and add the event say button
on
mouse
enter
i'm going to call the method this dot
increment count okay so once you're done
with that let's go ahead and define the
increment count method i'm going to copy
the same code that i've mentioned in my
click.js so i say copy this all right so
one change is that i change the name of
the method and
call it increment count again let's
define the count in our render method so
i say const count equals
this dot state and here i change x to
come now let's go ahead and import it in
our app.js so i say import counter
from
components and counter and let's define
it here all right let's save it and
let's run the code okay so as you can
see you see another button here
incremented to zero and every time i
move my cursor on the button
it increments mind you i'm not clicking
i'm just hovering my mouse okay to learn
how higher order components work we'll
have to pass counter.js and click.js as
parameters to give birth to an entire
new component so for that let's go ahead
and create another component for our hoc
let's call it
higher order dot js okay so i say import
react
from react after that i say const
updated component equals
original component that's going to be an
arrow function again and within curly
braces i define my class that is class
say new component extends
react
dot component inside let's define a
render method
that returns the original component with
a modification that is i want to type
the user i want to append the user
before the actual message is displayed
all right so let's go ahead and close
the tag and return new component and
let's export this say export
default updated component
now we import higherorder.js in our
counter.js and click.js and pass these
components as parameters so let's do
that let's go to our counter.js and here
i say
import updated component
from
dot slash higher order component and
here while exporting i say updated comp
and pass this as my parameter let's do
the same to click.js here i import
data.com from higher order component and
here i pass this as a parameter now here
in a higher order component we've
defined a property name and initialized
it to the user so we'll have to include
this in our other components that's
counter and click so let's do that and
here right before incremented to i say
this dot
props dot name let me save it let me do
the same thing here and say
this dot props dot name so if we go back
to our browser here you can see it says
the user clicked zero times and the user
incremented to zero okay so this
basically shows how react implements
reusability of components moving on our
next topic is pure components now
another way to create class component is
by extending pure component from react a
pure component avoids unnecessary
re-renders now how does it do it it does
not implement the should component
update method now you learn about this
method a little later in the video now
this method enables re-rendering of
components to the dom but a pure
component on the other hand ensures a
shallow comparison of states and props
and checks if a re-render is actually
necessary only then does it render to
the dom a react component can be
considered pure if it renders the same
output for the same state and props so
let's take an example to explain pure
components so let's go back to our vs
code and create two component classes
one for a regular component and the
other for a pure component now using
this example i'll show you exactly how
pure component is more helpful okay so
let's create a
purecomponent.js file
i say
pureform.js so here i'm going to use a
snippet rpce that is going to create a
pure component class let me get rid of
this export and here in my div tag i'll
display the text say i'm
the pure component all right now let's
go ahead and create a regular component
let me call it
regularcomponent.js and here i'm going
to use the snippet rce and the message
that i want to display is
i'm
the regular component so to draw a
comparison between the regular component
and the pure component let's create a
parent component for the two so let me
create one here i'll call it parent
component.js and this is again going to
be a regular class component and here i
display the message i am the parent
component to change the state of the
component we are going to make use of a
constructor so let's use the snippet our
const and here let me create
name you can give anything and i say
simply learn now we make use of the
component did mount lifecycle method to
set a time interval now don't worry
about this we're going to learn about it
a little later in the video so moving
ahead i'm going to make use of the
method and say component
did mount and here i say set interval
the first argument is going to be an
arrow function and the second will be
the time interval and i'm going to be
setting it to 3 seconds now within the
arrow function i'll make use of the set
state function to set the state of my
property however i do not change the
name i keep it simply on itself moving
on let's import pure component and the
regular component into our parent
component and then pass name as a
property so to do that first import pure
comp
from pure component and then i say
import regular com from regular com.js
and here let's say regular comp name
equals this dot state dot
name and i say pure component name
equals this
dot state dot name now let's include the
property name in both our regular and
pure components so to do that let's just
say this dot
drop dot name and here i again say this
dot prop dot name and finally let's
import parent component into our app.js
component so here i say import parent
com from okay and here let me define
parent.com
so now if you look at the browser we
have i'm the parent i'm regular
component simply learn and i'm the pure
component simply done we've got the
result as expected now to check if the
pure component is actually re-rendering
or not let's include simple console.log
statements so here i say clg snippet and
here i say
pure
component
render and in my regular component i do
the same thing i say console.log regular
component
render now let's do the same in our
parent component as well here i say
parent
component random all right so let's go
back to our browser and inspect it in
our console first the parent component
gets rendered then the regular component
and then the pure component after that
for every three seconds only the parent
component and the regular component is
rendered for the same state and prop the
pure component is not re-rendered so in
conclusion pure components optimize
react codes and also improves
performance so coming to the last topic
component life cycle so basically
comprehend life cycle explains the
stages the component goes through the
entire life cycle of a component can be
divided into three parts we have
mounting updation and unmounting so the
first thing that gets invoked in the
life cycle is component will mount it is
invoked right before the initial
rendering occurs then we have the
rendering method now once the component
is inserted into the dom component did
mount gets involved coming to the next
phase we have updation when a complaint
receives props component will receive
props gets invoked set state is called
when the state of the property changes
so every time there is a change react
decides whether the next component state
should trigger a re-render or not to do
that should component update method is
called component will update is invoked
right before re-rendering after
re-rendering component did update is
called that makes updates to the dom and
the last phase is unmounting component
will unmount method does all the
necessary cleanup and erases all the
allocated memory and cycles
in our previous video we learnt about
react.js components in detail and now
moving ahead let's learn about another
striking feature of react.js called
props props short for properties allow
the user to pass arguments or data to
components a pairing component can pass
additional information to its children
using props properties help make
components more dynamic props are passed
to components in the ways similar to
that of html track attributes now we'll
look at this a little later in the video
props in a component are read only and
cannot be changed one thing to remember
is that props are sent by the parent to
the children components hence the
children components cannot make any
changes to these props now that we've
learned about props in brief let's go
ahead and create our application using
props if you're new to this tutorial i
suggest you go to the react installation
and react components video on our
channel so back in my code editor that
is vs code i've opened a folder called
react props
and now i'm going to create a component
a class component and i'll call it class
props dot js so let's create the class
component i give rce the snippet
and here i display a message saying an
h1 tag basically
[Music]
all right
now let me get rid of export here and
import it in my app.js main component
here i say import
class props
all right now we define the class
component in our render method
let's say
all right
now if we go back to the browser you see
hello learners welcome to simply
learning now let's say we want to
individually welcome every student
instead of retyping the message for
everybody we can pass their names as
props now let's see how to do that now
we pass the name as a property from the
main component that is app.js to the
child component and render this onto the
browser so let's do that so here
while i'm defining my child component i
say name
i save it and here in my child component
instead of learners
i say i use the keyword this
dot props
dot name
let me save it and if you look at the
browser we'll have
one welcome to simply learn now let's go
ahead and welcome learner two and
learner three so i again say class props
name
equals
learner two
all right so if we save and look at the
browser we'll have all the three
learners displayed on the browser we can
also pass multiple props to the child
component now say for example we want to
welcome the student from a particular
place so we say welcome learner1 from
place x so i can here define another
property say place
and say place
similarly i can do it for the rest too
say place y
now let's go back to our class props.js
component and here say hello
from
this dot props
dot
place
let me save it and if you look at the
browser now we have hello learner1 from
place x place y and place z we can also
display whatever we want between the
opening and closing tags when invoking a
component now this is facilitated using
props.children reserved keyword now let
me explain to you
how it's done with an example here let's
split the self and closing tag into
an opening and a closing tag and in
between them let me display a message
within the paragraph tag let me say
and in my
child component
after my h1 tag
let me use a paragraph tag and here
let's use the reserved keyword this dot
props dot children
so let's save it
and now if you look at the browser you
can here see the message displayed child
component so prop stop children can be
used when components do not know about
their children ahead of time this is
commonly seen in components like sidebar
and dialog that represent generic boxes
so let's go ahead and create a button
tag and check again
so here
i'll split it and add a button tag
and say click
and let's check our browser
here we go
we get the output as expected all right
we saw the usage of props for class
components similarly we can use it for
functional components so let's go ahead
and create a functional component let me
call it
i say import
react from
react
and then i say function
function props
and here i return
an h3 tag
[Music]
i'll say this is
functional component
and i'll return another h3 tag
saying
hello learner
so let me save this
and let's export it
export
default
[Music]
function props
and import it
in our app.js again
import
function prop from
[Music]
function problem
and here in our render method let's
define it
let me call
function prop
name
let me give learner 4
and
place
place say a
let me close it
and back in a functional component
instead of learner
i say
props dot name
let me save it
now if you look at our browser it gives
us an error it says props is not defined
so let's go back to our code editor and
pass props here
to our functional component also
let me define hello props dot name
from
props dot place
let me enclose it within the div tag
here
let me save it and now if you look at a
browser here we go we get the output as
expected
so let's begin and learn what exactly is
a state in react typically a state is an
object that stores the values of
properties belonging to a component now
these values can change over a period of
time either via user interactions or
network changes and the state helps
facilitate this functionality every time
the state changes react re-renders the
component to the browser the state is
initialized in the constructor a state
can also store multiple properties a
method called set state is used to
update the value of the state object now
this function performs a shallow merge
on the new and the previous state
conventionally a shallow merge ensures
that the previous state values are
overwritten by the new state values
moving on in our previous video we
learnt about props and although props
and state dictate and control the
behavior of a component they have
significant differences so let's go
ahead and draw a comparison between the
two firstly props in a component are
used to pass data and event handlers to
its children while state on the other
hand is used to store the data that has
to be rendered on the web page props are
immutable once set by the parent they
cannot be changed state holds volatile
data and can be changed over time props
can be used in functional and class
components while state is restricted to
class components props are set by the
parent component while a state is
generally updated by event handlers now
that we've learned all about state let's
go ahead and build an application to see
the working of state alright so in my
code editor that is vs code i've created
my application say state and here in my
source folder i have my app.js file now
here i'm going to get rid of all the
unnecessary code that i'm not going to
be using also i suggest you go through
the react installation on windows video
to help you get started with creating
your first application so let's create
our class component say class app
extends react dot component and inside i
have a render method that returns an
html tag
let's display a message welcome
let's follow the jsx conventions and
enclose all the html tags within the div
tag so i say
div
class name equals app we also have to
import the app.css file import
app dot css
so we save it and if you look at the
browser we have welcome now let's
beautify our code to do that let's add
some styling so here in my app.js class
component i say styles
equals
and i say font
style and i set it to say bold and i say
color say teal and here in my h1 tag i
say style equals
this
dot
styles so let me save it and if you look
at the browser now we have welcome in
teal and it's bold now let's go ahead
and create a class component to
understand state so first i create a
folder and i call it components and
inside this folder i create a class
component and i call it new comp dot js
and i use the snippet rce to create the
class component to give you an insight
into what we're doing today we'll
display a message asking the user to
subscribe to simply learn once the user
clicks on the subscribe button we
instruct them to click on the bell icon
and finally we display a thank you
message now to do all of this we're
going to make use of state and as
mentioned earlier we initialize the
state object in a constructor so let's
use the snippet r const to create a
constructor now in the state object we
initialize a property let's call it
message and we display a message saying
subscribe to simply learn let's save it
and here in our render method let's say
class name
equals app and let's create an h3 tag
and within the tag i display the message
so i say
this dot
state dot message let's save it and now
let's import it in our app.js component
so i have to get rid of export here and
here i say
import new comp from components and new
comp and let's define it here and say
new so we save it and look at the
browser it says subscribe to simply
learn all right again to make our code
look more presentable let's add in
styles so i'll just copy the same styles
that i've added here and i'll paste them
here and instead of bold i make it
italic
and
i change the color to say
purple and again in my h3 tag
i define style and initialize it to
distort styles so let me save it and now
if you look at the browser it's in
italic and it's in purple
okay so moving ahead let's create a
button that reads subscribe and once the
user clicks on it the button should read
subscribed and the message displayed
above should instruct the user to click
on the bell icon to do that let's first
create a button the message that i want
the button to read is subscribe however
this message gets changed once the user
clicks on the button so instead of
explicitly mentioning subscribe here i
create a prop i say sub
and i say subscribe here and back in my
render method i say this dot state
dot sub so let's save it and if you look
at the browser now you have a button
which displays a message subscribe now
once the user clicks on the button the
message displayed should change to click
on the bell icon to never miss an update
so let's create an event handler for
that so here
button on click i call another method
and let's call the method
button change okay so this method should
update the state and change the message
and sub values to do that we make use of
a set state method now a state can be
updated in response to event handlers
server responses or prop changes now all
the updation can be done using the set
state method now this is the general
syntax used by the method we'll have a
look at this further in the demo now the
set state method conventionally enqueues
all the updates made to the component
state and instructs react to re-render
the component and its children with the
updated state now let's go back to our
code editor and look at the working of
this method now here i define the arrow
function button change if you are not
familiar with arrow functions i suggest
you read up on them and this is the
general syntax and here i say this dot
set state and inside i change my message
to
hit the bell icon to never
miss an update and my sub value changes
to subscribed
let's save this and now if you look at
the browser when we click on the
subscribe button the message changes to
hit the bell icon to never miss an
update so moving ahead let's use a bell
icon so that the user can click on it
once he clicks on the image the image
changes and a thank you message appears
on the screen so for that i have two
images i have bell a and bell b so i
drag and drop both the images in my
components folder all right
now let's import these images into our
new com.js file here i say import bell a
from
bell a dot png and again i say import
bell b
from
dot
png all right let me save it to display
the image on the screen we make use of
the image tag now this tag has two
attributes one is the source attribute
that specifies the url and the other is
the alt attribute that specifies an
alternate text for the image so here in
my component i say i make use of a
paragraph tag that will help display the
image in the next line and then i use
the image tag now since my image changes
once it's clicked i have to define a
property and pass the event handler
click that will update the image so here
before specifying the source let's go
back to our state and define another
property
that is image url and let's set it to
bell a since that is the image that i
want to display first let me save it and
here in my image tag i say source equals
this dot state
dot image url and then we have the alt
tag and i do not want to display any
message so i leave it as it is now let's
save it and if you look at the browser
we have a bell displayed however now
let's change the dimensions of the bell
i do not want such a huge bell so back
in my vs code i define style with width
say 30 pixels
and a height with again 30 pixels let me
save this and now if you look at the
browser we have a smaller icon so once
the user clicks on this image the emit
changes and the message displayed here
gets updated to do that we'll have to
define an event so let's go back to our
vs code and here in my image tag let's
say on click i define a method say this
dot
image change and now we define this
method here i see image change i make
use of an arrow function again
and again i use the set state method i
update the image so i say image url is
now set to bell
b and the message
is updated to thank you
happy learning
so let's save this now and if we look at
the browser we see the image and once
clicked on it the image gets updated and
the message changes so finally let me
refresh the browser once and show the
full execution let me refresh following
the instructions let's click on the
subscribe button and now it says hit the
bell icon and once i do that the image
updates and the message changes
so let's start with creating a simple
demo on react.js and we're going to
create a simple application
that will connect to an online music
streaming service called spotify and we
will call our application music app so
let's get started the first step is to
first get the node.js platform and
server installed to do that let me go to
google and let's just type node.js
and here is the website nodejs.org
there are two versions available the lts
which is the stable version and the
current we'll prefer the stable so we'll
click on that and you can see we have an
option which is called save file the
moment this file is saved to the disk we
just need to double click on it and keep
clicking on the next button to get it
installed on our system and we also have
a documentation available here so which
explains most of the features of the
node platform and there are binaries
available for different os's mac windows
etc so you can select the right witness
32-bit 64-bit and the right os
and then go ahead and download the
specific version that suits
your platform and you can see here that
there are different there are also help
files available that will allow you to
go through the installation documents
for node.js installation on linux etc so
to start with uh i'm opening up the
command prompt and here is where we're
going to call the node package manager
using the node package manager which is
pre-installed with your standard
node.js installation we will initialize
our react application so we would say
react dash app and
we want to now go and create an
application called music app in this
folder so as a prerequisite for the demo
all we need to do is install node.js
from
node.js.org the official website just
download it and install it and that's
when you open the command prompt you
fire npm which stands for note package
manager in it for initialize react dash
app is a standard keyword to
initialize and create a skeletal
structure of a react.js application and
the name of the app is music app so
we'll hit enter we'll give this some
time and you can see it's
started downloading the core
react gs libraries and it is attempting
to create
our application so it's installing all
the prerequisite packages and scripts
that are required initialize and create
a new react.js application called music
app now once this application is created
all we would require is an online editor
so you could use an offline or an
on-premise editor as well so any editor
of your choice it could be atom or
sublime text or webstorm and for this
demo we're going to use visual studio
code which is
a free editor available by microsoft and
you can just google for visual studio
code again uh this is not visual studio
professional edition etc that we use for
building our c-sharp or mbc-based
applications this is a lightweight
editor for building javascript based
full step full applications so so while
this installs let's go and take a look
at uh visual studio code so this is the
visual studio code editor and this is
the editor that we've
installed directly downloaded from
visualstudiocode.com and installed it
and all we need to do is open up this
folder that would be created with all
the prerequisite files in it we just say
file open folder and we would open that
folder within our visual studio code
editor so we'll give it a while until
that application gets generated and once
it's created
we will again implement the component
based design and architecture and the
data flow between the components and we
also look at connecting to a live data
source
which is a json set of characters that
we would consume which is a restful
service the set of music tracks exposed
as a restful api endpoint by spotify
which is a premium streaming service we
will connect to that and we will look at
accessing some of the music tracks on
that website okay so we've got uh the
application created here so let's
minimize this and
we'll open up our editor all we've got
to say is file and open folder and
let me go to the react.js demo folder so
this is the music app that got created
and that's exactly what we're going to
open up here so we'll navigate to
that folder it's called music app we'll
select it
and have it opened in our application so
you can see here we've got a note
modules folder this has all of the
pre-installed packages that make up the
react.js library we've got a folder
called public which will have the
index.html file that's the root file
that will launch so this is the single
page application that we typically
create
in react you have a single page which on
which we're going to load multiple
components so that's the index.html and
then we could go and create
a folder structure currently if i open
the source folder we can see a single
app.js file and that basically is
the file that has uh the source code in
javascript for a single component which
we are interested in adding on to our
page as of now so we just have one
component which is the default root
component that's the app component and
it has its corresponding css file and
then we've got
the a public folder with the index.html
file which is going to be
the root html file that launches when we
run our application so let's uh go right
up here and
let's add
a link to an additional file so i'm
going to link to another style sheet
okay so we'd say relationship is equal
to stylesheet and the type is going to
be text
and css
and
we will reference a file called
reset dot css and this is a file that we
look at
adding up later on it doesn't exist at
this point in time so we will connect
this and that's purely for styling
purposes
so that we can have
all of our css styles defined there next
thing i'll right click on the public
folder we'll create a new file we'll
name this file as reset dot css so
that's going to be the css file that
will have all of the css
styling that we're going to apply and
i'm going to use a ready code snippet
for the css code so let me just uh okay
so i'll all i'll do is
i'll just go and pick up
a ready css file that i can just go and
use
if you look here i have a set of
css files that are created that we're
just going to use
within our application and
and that will avoid us uh spending a lot
of time on the styling so that we can
focus on our core concepts uh which is
actually learning how component based
architecture works and how do we set up
components and have data communication
between them in react so uh here is a
file called uh
reset.css let me just fire up
notepad and i'll just open up this file
copy up the text here and i'm going to
just paste it within uh reset.css and if
you look at the code uh very simple it's
all about uh styling so we've got uh
article aside etc all html5 tags set up
as display blocks so they take up the
entire width of the page we've got some
padding margin and font size etc defined
we've removed list styling for the
unordered and ordered list specifying
the line height for the body tag so
basically uh just styling up tables and
so nothing nothing to do with react here
it's just about simple uh css that we've
added up uh and now we need to actually
go in and dive into create creation of
the components that we need so let's
right click on the source folder so i'll
select the source folder we'll right
click there and that's where we're going
to create a new folder which is called
components okay so this is the
components folder now that's going to
hold
all of the components within it within
the components folder let me create
another new folder and i'm going to call
it app and this is exactly how we are
expected to structure all of the code
that we have now i already have a css
and app.js which are the root components
that were added by default and all i'm
going to do is i'm going to move them
within this folder called app okay so
there's a proper segregation of
responsibility and
all of the code that
deals with a particular component is all
added into respective folders and this
really improves the maintainability of
the application uh going forward now we
need some images
and i'm just going to make use of some
set of images that i've downloaded from
the web and
here are the set of images that i have
so i'm just going to copy all of them
and we'll come to our music app and we
go into the components and app folder
and that's where we're going to add all
of the files and you've seen all of
those image files getting added so these
are just icons and images we're going to
use for our music tracks inside our
application now
let's move to the app.css file and
this is where we've actually got uh
so the app.css file is the file that's
going to style up
the
all of the style rules that we've added
into the root app component and
this is what we'll have to
revamp so i'll just get rid of this code
and
we'll probably add something for the
body tag the html tag and the root
element let me say hash root and let's
set the height to 100
coming to all of the html across the
page we'll give it a font size of 10
pixels
and
the h1 elements
let me give it a padding of 0.77
and 0 let's set
a background color give it a background
color and just select
some random color here that can be
applied then we'll set up the text
alignment which is going to be the
center of the page we'll set up the font
family the font family is
and this is part of
sans serif what else do we add let's add
up the font size 1.88
and also the color so again uh these are
standard uh html and css elements so uh
nothing really that
has to be done that is specific to react
here so again we are bringing in the
highlight class so there is a class
called highlight that we will create
later in the
html view of this component and we will
set this to a red rgb component so
combination of 46 113 and 238 okay so
that's uh pretty much done let's move on
and also add up for the anchor tag let's
add up some text decoration and set it
to none so that the anchor tags don't
come up with those underlines and of
course we'll provide a color of hash
okay so a white color there now coming
to the h2 element for the h2 element
let's have font family and again i'm
going to use
so i'm going to use
the font family that we defined here
bracket and we change this to probably
1.55 okay now coming to the app tag uh
let me just save this and create a copy
of it uh there was some content that
i did delete and
i can simply go and make use of it so
i've just undone all of the deletion so
this is uh something that i can't
if i can use something i can just
probably use it from the tag below so
let me start with the height here and
let's say the height of the header is
100 percent of the app sorry not header
padding 0 17
the background and i'm going to change
that to background url so the background
url or let's say the background image
will have a url property okay and that
url is going to be dot slash vg1 dot
jpeg so that's the image that we've
added some in the previous step let's
also add
background size so we'll add background
size and set it to cover i also need a
background position that is the center
let's have background repeat which is
set to
no repeat so that we don't have the
image
in a grid format uh and then i would
need this bit of it let's take up the
font family we'll maintain the same font
family let's use font weight the font
weight is going to be 500 and the color
is going to be hash
so that's a white color then we come to
dot
app.playlist so that's going to be
another class that we are going to use
dot but app dash playlist is what we
we're going to name it and
let me say that the display should be
flex
flexible display and we will justify the
content to leave spaces
in between all right so that
finishes that bit and now uh
let's write up a media query for the
responsiveness of this page so this is
media for only screen and max width is
going to be one zero two zero pixels
okay and the class name that we'll
provide later is obviously app playlist
so for this screen size we would align
all the items to the center and we
change the flex direction okay so we
seem to be good with
the css for the app as of now and that's
the app.css
that we created let me save everything
okay let's check uh
for any kind of uh
additional so all three of errors no
errors now things are good in the app
css and it's time to move to the next
step of building this application uh now
we'll have to go and add up
the code for
the app.js file so let's dive into the
app.js file and this is where
we will actually need to go and add
all of the code that is required for the
app component so all the code that's
relevant to
the app component we are going to add up
inside this specific component itself
which is going to be obviously the
app.js file so we have skeletal code
which is import importing the react
library and
let me get rid of the basic sample logo
we'll have app.css that's getting
imported here
besides that lot of other files that
we'll have to get in so
let me import playlist and this is these
are the components that we'll create
as we go forward and we're going to get
this from the playlist folder
and the component the file is going to
be called playlist so we'll add that
then we'll have to go and also import
search bar so what we're basically doing
is we're going to split this app into
different components there's going to be
one component that manages uh the
playlist of all the tracks uh one
component will uh act as the search bar
so that's the search bar component that
we're going to add so searching for
tracks will be managed by this we'll
have another component that we'll create
that will get imported into the root app
component which is a search results so
this is going to display the record set
with the set of results as an outcome of
the search criteria so search results
slash
search results and finally we'll go and
import spotify that's the spotify
service from so we'll create a utility
folder which will hold
the code that connects us to spotify so
that's what we are adding up next so all
of the imports are done one component
that manages the search bar so that's
search bar search results let me correct
the spellings there that search results
that spotify and playlist so that's done
now let's move on to the class that
we're going to create here so let's
create a class app that goes and extends
dot component so that's going to be a
react.js component so that's a
constructor we discussed about props or
properties and state management and
that's what we are implementing we are
using the super keyword as a best
practice so that all the properties are
initialized in the constructor and also
we pass the values up the chain to the
super class which is the root component
class now we're going to initialize
a variable called state that's going to
manage the state and we are interested
in tracking our search results so we'll
have multiple results so we'll store
that as an array the playlist would have
different names so we'll just call ours
new playlist that's the default name and
we will also store a list of tracks
which is going to be playlist tracks so
playlist tracks is going to be a list of
tracks and let's close
this block okay and this two is going to
be initialized within the constructor so
we'll add it here and now we need to do
the binding we discussed uh data binding
so let's look at
creating a search variable which will
hold this dot
search dot bind and bind to the context
of this very class so we are passing
this pointer then we'll create another
variable called add track which to this
dot add track dot bind and all this
functionality is what we're going to add
going forward so right now we're just
setting up the bindings then we'll have
capability to remove a track so we'll
say remove track so remove track equal
to this dot remove track dot pint and
let's fix that so and all of this too is
going to be initialized as part of the
constructor so that's where we're going
to add it then we need to update update
the playlist name so we need
functionality that will help us to
update the name of the playlist so
functionality that helps us to update
the playlist name so this dot update
playlist
name is equal to this dot
update playlist name dot bind and this
is the pointer that we'll pass i need to
save the playlist so this dot
save playlist
equal to this dot save playlist dot find
and pass this and then i would also need
to remove the track that has been
searched for from the playlist so remove
track search go to this dot
okay remove track search and
dot find
and finally one last function that
executes
all of these which probably will bind to
bind to this context so all the
declarations are done in the constructor
now we need to provide the definitions
for all the methods that we actually
have added here so let me select this
tab inside and let's start with the
search function so we'll define the
search first it takes
some variable value that it searches on
and then i'm going to say spotify dot
search i'm going to search for term dot
then and that's an observable so the
moment it the search returns a value it
it's going to call this
callback function and that's when we
want to set the state and we're going to
set the state for search results to
whatever is passed by the system so the
search results are going to be returned
as a callback and that's what we store
as an updated state now coming to the
add track method so let's scroll up and
we'll say add track and this will take
the track to be added let's declare a
temporary variable called tracks equal
to this dot the current state of all the
tracks that are there in the playlist
now if
track start
find i'm going to call the find method
so if we are able to find which means
that the track is already there in the
playlist then we would not want to add
it if it's not there in the playlist
that's when we would want to go and edit
the triple equal to is an equality
operator that will check for both a
watch value match and a match on the
data type as well okay so if the track
is uh already saved to nothing if the
track is not safe just track the track
id because that is the track that will
uh have to be added if it's not if it's
already there then just return if it's
not there then we've got to go to this
variable called tracks we'll use the
javascript method called push and we
will push the current track into this
tracks
array and then update the state so we
want to set the state of the playlist
tracks and this is how uh your state
management that we discussed in detail
is actually being practically
implemented here okay so the track has
been added now let's talk about the
remove track so that's the remove track
function and that's the track that we
want to remove so let's let tracks equal
to this dot state dot playlist tracks
those the set of current tracks that we
have and
let track search another temporary
variable equal to this dot the current
state of the search results then let's
take the tracks array equal to track
start filter so filter is of javascript
function that will again allow you to
remove a certain value create a
temporary variable called current track
use the lambda operator and if the
current track dot id is not equal to the
track dot id which means this particular
track is
not there in the list okay so you need
to remove that and again i have a method
called as unshift which will actually
get rid of the track in the array and
then we've got to so we'll search
whether that
track is existing in the tracks array if
it is then we simply want to remove it
if not we do nothing so we set the state
we need to update the state of the
playlist because the track has been
removed so the playlist tracks will have
to be updated with this tracks array
okay then we go for remove track search
that's the next method that also will
take a track as a parameter okay here we
are going to say let tracks which is
another temporary variable we'll give it
this current state of search results and
then we are going to say tracks equal to
tracks dot filter current track current
track dot id not be equal to the track
dot id and then this is where we would
want to say this dot set state and we'll
pick up search results
and let's go and assign that to track so
that's the updated uh set of tracks
after making that change let's remove
this and correct it okay so that's fine
so the remove track uh
is now the remove track and the remove
track search is now in place let's add
the do these functions which actually
again takes track as a parameter and
here we'll say this dot add track okay
so it adds the track and then it removes
the track from the search criteria so
the search component which is managing
searching of the tracks that will go and
remove it from there after adding the
new track so that's a combined
operation we want to execute then i've
got update
playlist name which will take the name
of the track to update and this dot set
state the playlist
name is what we need to update with the
name that is passed to this function
then we've got to save playlists so
here we let me create a constant
variable constants are variables whose
values will not frequently change we'll
take all the track uris dot state dot
playlist tracks
will be dot map create a temporary
variable called track track dot uri so
we actually want to go and uh now save
this on a spotify so that's the reason
we'll access
spotify's safe playlist method this dot
state dot playlist name comma track uris
and if that is successful we then go
into a callback so that's the callback
anonymous function where we're going to
say this dot
set date and the playlist
name that we want to create on spotify
will be called new playlist so that's
the custom name that i want to provide
and the playlist tracks
define that this closes here
okay so that's for the update on
spotify now here is where
the render method is going to return the
html now this html is the view and react
simplifies this by having the javascript
and the html in the same
file so you can actually go and access
the variables you've declared in the
script directly in your html view
and synchronize and bind the data
together so it helps from a
maintainability perspective so even
though everything is in the same file
it's well classified and differentiated
into different code blocks so we'll add
the anchor tag and we'll say href is
http localhost so that's the default
server port on which this application
will run okay and we want to give it a
custom url name of music or file so the
h1 terminates will then say div class
name equal to app within that this is
how we're going to inject a search bar
that's going to be the search bar
component injected here and on search so
that's the custom event we will call a
method called search so on search we
just call we bind to a method called
this dot search then we'll open up
another div here we'll have class name
equal to app dash playlist and if you
remember that's exactly the css
class name that we refer to in the css
file we have another component called
search results
that we're going to inject here
and
that's going to be search results here
search results will be equal to this dot
state dot search results so that's how
we can actually go and bind so that's
simple data binding the component is
going to be displayed with the data
bound and if somebody says add if if i
click on the add button for search
results
do these so it will add that new track
to the playlist by calling binding to
the 2ds function and it will remove it
from the search results text box then we
have another component called playlist
and here the playlist tracks
will be bound to this dot state dot
playlist tracks okay so on the top if
you look here we started with defining
all the function declarations in the
constructor then we provided the
function definitions okay that's how and
this that we passed refers to the
context of the current
component itself so whatever you put
into the app component or into the
respective component those values will
be then passed out here to these
individual functions okay so that's with
the playlist couple of things we'll have
to do is if somebody changes the name of
the track so on name change is going to
be another custom event where we have to
call this dot update playlist name and
we also have remove functionality so to
remove a track we would say equal to
this dot remove track on save equal to
this dot save playlist okay so that's
done and we close this so we seem to be
pretty much
on track the export
app will make this all of these
functions accessible across other
components it's very similar to the
public access specifiers etc that you
provide uh in other programming
languages so that's done we've created
our app component now let's create
another folder under components and
we've got to define all our various
components here this folder is going to
be for the search bar so we'll name it
search bar we'll add
two files within it the search bar dot
css okay and another file that we need
here is
search bar dot js
so that's in terms of the search bar
let's start with the css file so we'll
start with first styling search bar we
will say that the display
should be flex flex
direction should be column we want all
the items to be aligned at the center so
that's align item center then we'll add
up padding so padding top
is going to be 6.94
rpm and
margin
bottom is going to be
6.33 rem all right now let's add up for
the search bar so that's search bar
we'll add
for the input element we want the width
to be 287 pixels the padding to be zero
point eight eight
zero the border should be one pixel
solid white the border radius
will give a slight rounded edge uh to
give a web 3.0 look and feel so we'll
set up the border radius then we've got
uh margin bottom so we've got a pattern
margin
that we want to add up then we have
color so let's add up the color c3f so
that's the color black then let's add
text alignment of
center and let's add up a font size of
one rem okay so that's how we've set
this up let's add
the search bar input is going to be so
if someone focuses so focus is the got
focus so if someone clicks inside so the
end user goes and clicks inside the text
box
we change the outline to none okay and
so for the search bar we are interested
on input and if the input is
focused so that's the event that we are
looking for and then we would have a
button called search button so on the
search button the cursor will set it to
pointer so that's the cursor pointer the
width we set it to 8.11
rem the padding we are going to set up
to
0.77 rem and 0 the border radius
we'll set it to 54 pixels so we get a
slightly uh well defined search button
with a nice little border let's also add
background color hash one db nine five
four that gives me a color then i've got
my text alignment let's set that to
center then we've got uh a font family
let's set up the font family to the same
standard font 8t
and it's a part of the sans serif family
then we'll set up the font size to 0.833
rem correct this
and finally we will need
transition so all of these are basic
css properties so that will add a slight
transitional effect with a delay of
that many milliseconds
so transition background color we've
provided what else let me scroll up
let's also provide a border here so
we'll remove
in fact let's remove the border we we
would not want a border on the button
that would look odd so i'll get rid of
the border and color we'll specify as
per our standard color that we've been
using okay so that's the color we've
specified and then i've got font weight
of 500. finally we'll take
the search button and on the search
button we will register for the hover
event so if someone takes their mouse
over the button that's the over the
event in that case if we hover around
the button we would want
the background
color to change so it will appear to
have a slight little glow there a mouse
pointer moves over the button okay so
that's the opacity and the rgb
combination so that completes
the css file for the search bar and we
obviously now need to go and
get the code in for
our search bar component and that's
exactly what we are going to do next so
let's start with setting up the code for
the search bar first thing let's go and
import
react from
react next thing we would want to do is
import
the search bar dot
css file then we define a class called
search bar which extends
react dot
component we define our constructor and
we go and
pass these parameters to the base class
we also define
the state we'll just need one variable
here which is the term to search for in
the search bar and then let's say this
dot
will define a function called handle
term change which is going to be equal
to this dot handle handle term change
dot
find so that's going to be the first
function then a function that will do
the searching for us
which is this dot
search so that's the search function and
we'll have it bind to this
then we've got this dot
handle
enter so the moment we enter into that
search text box
handle enter dot find this
so the functions are ready now let's go
for the first one which is handle term
change
we'll pass it a system defined keyword
of event this dot
set state and for the term
we will use the event keyword we will
get
the value that is there inside that text
box the moment the search term the user
is entered changes so the search
criteria changes we trap the updated
value then in the search function we
will update
the local property props dot on
search
okay so we'll access the on search and
pass it the updated term and then we got
the handle enter on which
we're also going to pass the system
define event keyword so if there's any
data flowing along with the event we are
interested in it in this case the data
is the key code that the user is
pressing and if it is 13 that indicates
that's the ascii key code for the enter
button so if the enter is hit then the
user is completed entering the search
criteria and we need to start searching
and that's where we write our render
method that's going to render the html
view and we return the complete view
here so that's the view now that we want
to return let's say diff class name
equal to search bar then on the input
text box
we will use placeholder equal to enter
song album
or artist that you want to search for on
change
on the on change event the moment the
term changes we connect that to handle
term change we already have an
function that manages that and the
moment
keys are pressed and released so on key
up is where we would want to connect to
this dot handle enter okay and this is
place bracket that i'll have to put up
here so in the render function uh we're
going to return a value i shouldn't
forget to export the search bar okay so
that's uh what i want to export so we've
exported that okay so at the end of this
uh what we've done is we've written a
render method we've written our div tag
here is where we'll go and close
the div tag we've added an input and
here is where i'm going to add a button
provide a class name called search
button and the moment the end user
clicks on the button we're going to
connect it to this dot
search and we close
the button tag within the button tag
search so that
completes the
render function so in the render
function again let's run through all of
what we've written we started with
extending react.component we then added
a constructor passing props to the super
class constructor we created
state we set it to a value of
term and null so the state currently we
defined as term then we said handle term
changes search and handle enter should
be functions
that we want to add then handle term
changes
we defined search we defined and handle
enter we've also defined then we used
render render we said is going to return
to us
the html that we've specified okay we
dumped all the html that we want this
component to return to us
so on change and on key up
functions that
or two events that we connected to where
we called handle term change and handle
enter then we added a button where we
registered for the click event and
connected it to this dot search so all
the three functions uh that we
are actually written uh so two things
we've completed now
uh in the app class
okay if you look at the app class we've
actually defined a set of functions here
that deal with the playlist and adding
applications etc adding tracks delete
removing tracks
then we've created
the search bar okay so we saw that the
search bar also we have specified a set
of functions
and all the functions that we defined we
have taken care to structure every
component separately so the search
component is doing something completely
different which is managing the search
bar we have the core the root app
component in which we have imported all
of the other set of javascript classes
uh that we are creating and that's how
the entire application is now structured
so and that's the core
concept when you're working with react
where you would actually have every
separate
block of
code or every separate functionality
handled in a different component
altogether so we've completed the search
bar component as well so two components
done and two components uh good to go so
we've got to start up on the next set of
components that we will need to build
and the next component is
the track component that will manage
individual tracks so a new folder a new
file called track.css
and
track.js
so that's going to manage
the tracks for us
so let's start with dot track we would
say display is flex
align items
center border bottom one pixel solid
rgba
256 0.8 that's the opacity then let's
come to track action so we'll use all of
these classes uh when we write up the
html view we'll add a padding here of
0.5 we'll set up a font size
of
1.05 set up a transition
color of
0.25 s
order of 0 pixel and
a background color of rgba
000 color hash
so that's the color that we continue to
use then we bring in track another class
track action and if we hover over this
class we want
the gb values change to 265 265 2 6 5 5
is the last parameter so that's the
hover
then we have track information so track
information is the next class that we're
dealing with we'll add the flex
parameter first display flex and
then flex
direction
is going to be column let's have justify
content
set up as
center and let's have height as
180 pixel so that's a track information
let's have another track information and
the h3 tags nested inside that
for all the h3 tags nested inside that
we'll need a margin bottom of 0.22
rpm finally let's have track information
and paragraph tag we'll have the font
size
of
0.83 rem and a font weight of 300
and a color as well that we'll add so
let's add up a color here rgba 2 6 256
256 and 0.8 okay so that's uh that's in
terms of the css and let's move to the
track and we'll move into the javascript
file so let's move into
so let me take what we added in the
search bar i'll go to the track.js
this will change to track dot css
okay the constructor this will change to
add track so add track change this to
add track this is
remove track change this to remove track
get rid of this
and that's going to be
the add track function and here we are
going to say uh
this dot props
so we'll modify this this dot
props
dot on add this dot props dot track and
then we have the remove track so that's
going to be the remove track function
this function is not required so this
dot prop start on remove and this is the
track that we would want to go and
remove we'll add up another function
called
render action so this is going to be a
function uh that we are defining called
render action and in this we'll just
check if this dot props dot is remove if
this dot props dot is
removable so in that case
we would want to return so this is a
view action method that we are adding
which is going to go and add this button
with a class called as track action that
we've already written the css for and
this button will actually get added via
this render action function and this dot
remove track is what it's going to map
to
let's close this
this is going to point to this specific
function so that's uh the closing button
tag okay so the closing button tag is
what
we've added there and the binding is
what we have done to this dot remove
track and
we will terminate this here
so now the render action uh let's also
have the return here and we just add up
the button and this is going to add
track so you can look at how the
component is completely dynamic uh in
nature so we have two buttons that are
going to be added this button with the
hyphen is going to remove the track this
button with a plus sign is going to add
the track and you can actually see how
simply it was done in a render action
function so the render action function
actually helped
with uh checking that if
on the value of the props
and if the user uh depending on
the action performed you will actually
be able to remove a track or add a track
from the existing playlist okay and then
uh
the class name here is now going to be
track the class name for
uh the enclosing div inside it so let me
get rid of this
the class name for the enclosing div
here
is going to be
track dash information within it we'll
add h3 we'll bind to this dot props dot
track dot name so the name of the track
is going to get bound here then in the
paragraph we will find to this dot props
dot track dot artist
and
with some gap this dot props dot track
dot algo so that's what
we've data bound to
and then let me add an iframe an iframe
allows us to
very easily inject some content into the
page within a small embedded window the
source parameter of the frame is going
to be https
open dot so here i'm connecting to the
spotify stream
spotify.com slash embed slash track and
close this so that's the spotify stream
that we're going to connect to and this
dot props dot track dot id so that's the
track id the width is going to be 300
the height parameter this the height
parameter is going to be 80 of the
iframe and
the frame border is going to be zero and
the allow
transparency
so that's the opacity we'll say true
let's add allow
encrypted media so if spotify has
encrypted media that also would be
embedded here and we can also have the
title set to preview so that's uh with
the iframe okay at the bottom is where
we would want to so this could be an
empty element and we can close it
right around here so we wouldn't need
this part and then here i'm just going
to say this dot
render action so we call the render
action method uh which will actually
give us plus minus button to add and
remove uh
new element okay and that's
what we can actually go and add up there
so let's check now whether all that
we've done is good to go fine so
everything looks good
in terms of the track component now and
we have all of the functions in place
it's now time to jump into the
next component that we would require
after the track component and
that's going to be the track list so
this is going to be a list component
that will comprise of a list of tracks
inside it so we'll create a new folder
call this track list
and that's going to have
track list
css
and it's going to have
track list dot js
so that's the track list
component now which
we're going to go ahead and use
and the css we don't need much
so let's just say track list
and we just provide a width of 100
okay that's all we need uh in the css so
let me add this in the css file save
this
and come to the js file now which is
going to have
the track list code that we will need to
add up so here again i'm going to say
import react
from react we'd also want to import
track list dot css
and
we also want to go and get track because
this component is going to be made up of
a collection of tracks individual tracks
so we want to get this from track slash
track and we'll define class track list
which is going to go and extend
react dot
component
we just need the render method here
because this just needs to go it does
not really have any state of itself it
simply goes and returns a list of
individual tracks
so this class name is going to be track
list
and we'll bind to this dot props dot
tracks dot map create a temporary
variable
and this will go and return
the track component which is going to
bind to individual track data the key is
going to be track dot id so the key is
going to be
track dot id
and on add on adding a new track we want
to bind to this dot properties don't and
we already have on add defined so that's
what we connect to we add up my
base bracket here okay and
then we would also need
is removal equal to
this dot props dot is removal and the on
remove will do this dot prop start on
remove so that's for the track removal
and
so we've got our track list
uh oh yes we'll have to go and
also close the tip tag correctly and
also we need to go and export so we'll
have to go and export the track
list
so we've got one more component done
which is track list and let's move on to
the next component now so we've got app
which is root we've got the search file
that takes care of entering the search
criteria we've got individual tracks
that are searched and returned and we've
got a track list that manages a set of
track records so the track is more
relevant to the playlist and then we've
got the search results also to manage
once we search for some set of tracks so
we'll add a new folder which manages
search results
and this is going to have
search results dot css
and it's going to have
search results dot js
okay so we need a search results dot css
and js and here in the css file we'll
keep it simple for the search
results so we say search results we'll
set up the width of 50
we
set up the height of 950
pixels
we'll say
overflow y is
scroll we'll say padding is 0.88
rem background color will be rgba
23 23 0.7 and we will use the box model
so we'll provide a shadow dropping
shadow of zero for pixels to pixels to
pixels ash
and then uh let's add
a scroll bar so
webkit
and mozart are the constants specific to
mozilla and
chrome browsers
so they target certain animated features
etc or properties
that are specific to those individual
browsers that's the reason we use those
constants
and then we'll also add a media query
that if it goes with a max
with one zero two zero pixels
in that case dot search results
width is 90 percent
with a margin bottom of 2
okay so
we're going to add hyphen so it's hyphen
webkit scroll bar zero pixel width
and we've set
transparent background so that's that's
about it with
the css i need to get to the uh js file
now let's move to the search results
js file and
that's where we will now have to go and
add up
the component code for search results
and let me take
pick this up from track list
add it up here this would be
search results and
we need the results will return to us a
list of tracks so we'll have to get uh
track list
this would be track list
and
i'm just going to return class name will
also be search results so that's the
component and this is going to export
out search results so it's accessible
across
other components then we've got h2 with
results
let's go and create
track list with a set of tracks and we
will bind it to this dot props dot
search results
and on the on add we are going to bind
to this dot props dot on add so we
already have that so that uh basically
completes
search results and
that leaves us with the last component
which is going to manage the playlist
for us so we'll add up a new books we'll
add up a new folder in components
and that's going to be playlist
and within that
we will have a playlist dot css
and
a playlist dot js
so that's our
playlist component now that
we're going to work with and the
playlist component is
uh we'll first set up
the css that we will need
to add up to the playlist and i'm just
going to
pick that up from
my code snippet so that's my playlist
and let me get all of that css here so
that's uh just a css for the playlist
nothing to do with react again pure css
let me get
into the js file and that's where we
will need to go and add all of our
component code so again let me go to the
track.js
the track list rather let me get this
and add it
out here we'll make some small changes
this is going to be playlist
i need to import the track list
because the playlist is going to contain
a list of tracks
this is going to be
playlist and
let me
here this will be playlist and we'll
leave this
for later okay let me also get
the constructor in so we'll add up the
constructor here and just one
function that we will need here which is
handle name change you know if i need to
change the name of the playlist so
handle name change and that's exactly
the function that we will need to write
code for so that's the event
and this dot props
dot on
name change that's when we'll say event
dot target
dot value so we get the updated playlist
name coming to the render we now need
the input input
is going to be on change equal to
this dot
handle name change
the default
value we have already provided with a
hard coded value which is new playlist
so that's the default value if
not provided then we'll just pick up the
default value then we've got
track list so track list is
what i will add the tracks i'm going to
bind to this dot props dot playlist
tracks
so we're going to bind this to playlist
and here we will say
is
removal equal to
true and on remove
equal to we'll bind that to this dot
props
dot on remove finally we'll need a
button
we will use
class name equal to playlist
dash
save that's what we've added in the css
click equal to this dot props
dot on save and here we're going to say
save to spotify so that's with the
playlist and yes we need to go and
export playlist and not track list
now we need to uh do a quick lookup
in spotify so let's go to this website
called developer.spotify.com
and once once we sign in uh and create
an id it takes us to our dashboard
that's where we can create a sample
application
the name of the application will be
musical file okay and
we'll say that we are building uh some
kind of desktop app for example for
which we want to connect this to and
we'll also need to provide uh so we'll
say next
refresh the dashboard so it's uh
asking me for a login so let me login
once more so moment i login that's going
to be description and i'll say maybe
this is why i need it i'll say no not
commercial integration agree with the
terms and conditions and we will say
submit
and that's the application that has got
created and now i can say edit settings
and
the redirect url here is what is
important
so it should accept connections from
http localhost 3000 that's the port on
which we will host our application okay
and we'll say save okay so that's uh now
there's a client id that is generated
here for my app which is unique so i'll
just copy that up let me come up to my
application under the source folder i'm
going to add a new folder called util
and under that a new file called
spotify.js
so we will start with
adding our code to the spotify.js file
that we've just created as a new file
within the newly created util folder the
first line of code is going to define a
client id variable that equates to the
client id that we will generate on
spotify so this is going to be the
spotify generated client id which is a
unique id associated for the developer
to connect to the spotify api and we
will look at the source of that as we go
through the demo the next variable that
we'll create is the redirect url or
let's call it redirect uri and that will
equate to localhost colon 3000 which is
the port and we'll create another
variable called the access token let's
also create another constant variable
called spotify and this will work like a
function expression so we'll equate it
to a function called get access token
and we will say if access token is true
then return the access token now let's
declare a constant variable called
access token match which will be equal
to window dot location dot href dot
match
and we will say this is equal to access
token which will be equal to and we will
give a rejects expression to do a
pattern match ampersand so that we can
actually get into the url and extract
the token information from that and
hence
the patent match is crucial here another
constant
variable called
expires in match
equal to window dot location dot href
dot match here we will read the expiry
information using another regex
expression from the url ampersand
asterisk so that's the second constant
variable we've created now we will say
if access token match and
expires in match in that case
the access token should be equal to
access token match of 1. then we create
a variable called
expires in equal to we'll do a typecast
to number and we will take the first
parameter from the expires in match
that's done then we will say
window.settimeout
and we're going to say access token
equal to comma expires in multiplied by
thousand then we will say
window.history.push
state and we will say access token we
pass the second parameter as null the
last parameter as slash
and close this and we will return access
token else
we will say const access
url equal to https
accounts.spotify.com
slash
authorize
client underscore id equal to dollar
client id ampersand response type equal
to token ampersand scope equal to
playlist dash
modify so we are actually building the
url that will now get generated so we
will say modify dash public and redirect
url equal to dollar redirect uri so we
have constructed the url now that will
go out and get generated in the browser
and here we are going to say window dot
location equal to access url then we
will add the search criteria function
which accepts a term as a parameter to
search on here we will say constant
access token equal to spotify dot get
access token so we get a reference to
the same access token return we call the
fetch function and we're going to pass
https
api dot
spotify.com slash
v1 slash
search question mark that's the query
string that we will add type equal to
track and ampersand g equal to dollar
and we will pass term comma as the
header information we will need to pass
the authorization where we will say that
the pairer is dollar access token dot
then response
return response dot json dot then so the
return of this function once it
completes we will then call the next
function so json response
and then we will say
return response dot json after that
another then block so we'll now say
jsonresponse
and if
not
jsonresponse.tracks
in that case we will return
an empty array else
we will return jsonresponse dot tracks
dot items dot and we will pass
we'll create track as
a variable with a lambda expression and
we'll create a temporary json object
with id and that's where we want to
associate track dot id that was returned
as the search result the name is going
to be associated with track dot name the
artist is going to be associated with
track dot artists of zero dot name the
album is going to be track dot album dot
name and the uri we will equate track
dot uri so that completes uh this block
will open the next and we this will be
the save playlist which will take the
name and the track uris and here we will
check if not
name or
not track uris dot len in that case we
simply return out of the code and then
we declare a constant variable called
access token which will be equal to
spotify dot get access token so we get a
reference to the access token we then
declare headers authorization bearer is
going to be dollar access token and we'd
create a user id and now we will return
the fetch result where we will pass
https
api dot spotify dot com slash v1 slash
me so that's the url comma headers will
be the header information then we call
the then function declare response as a
variable use the lambda expression and
access response dot json we use the then
block to declare json response
here we say user id equal to
jsonresponse.id
and then we return fetch
https
api dot spotify.com
slash v1 slash users slash dollar of
user id slash playlist so this is how
we've constructed the urls manually here
we will assign headers to the headers
variable we'll assign method as post so
the data is sent as part of the body and
not as part of the url and
as the body we will say
json.stringify to convert this parameter
name and then we will generate a
response variable to
response.js
and then we'll create jsonresponse with
the lambda operation we'll create a
constant playlist id which is equal to
jsonresponse.id we will return fetch
https
api dot spotify.com
v1 users
dollar user id slash playlist slash
dollar again we are constructing the url
so playlist id will be replaced here
then we will say tracks
and close this comma and here again we
will say headers would equate to the
headers variable be constant headers and
this
goes here okay everything fixed now so
here we're going to say headers should
equate to headers and
the method is going to be post and the
body is going to be json dot stringify
uris track uris and we close this we
close this block we close this block and
we close this block so that completes
our code of course one more thing we
have to do which is export this class
out so export default spotify and that
completes the code for
the spotify.js
which is part of our utils class so
let's move on now to the next step so
uh here is
uh the client id that we'll have to
exactly match so i'll copy this client
id and provide it here so that's the
client id uh that we actually need and
we could also store it
out here
so that's the uh client id and that's
the redirect url that we've also defined
there and we just create an access token
if your access token is true we return
access token
so the access token is something that we
are going to do a match from uh
the moment we try and connect with this
particular url and you can look here
that this is the access url that we are
trying to connect with okay with the
client id and post fixed with the
redirect url right and then i've got a
simple search function which returns an
observable so we try to fetch data using
the search term that we provided okay we
try to fetch data using the search term
provided if we are successful we get a
response of the data and accordingly
we'll iterate over the json response and
get a list of tracks out of it and do a
mapping of this json object to the track
id name artist information album name
etc and here uh just like a data access
layer very similar to a data access
layer we've got a save function which
will save this data to spotify as well
so i've got a save playlist and i've got
search so these are the two functions
which will go and connect to the spotify
service uh by using this client id
and it will allow me to
access that information in terms of
returning a stream of json data and will
then allow me to
go ahead and push that json data into
our application so now we
actually need to start up the
application so i'll go to the terminal
and rather let me go to view and
bring out the terminal so this is the
integrated terminal that's there in the
tool and it just opens powershell from
which you can actually fire your
commands so i'm going to say note
package manager npm start to actually
start up this application so that's
going to do a full compile and
so we will fire this up give access so i
need to grant access to that port 3000
let's give it time to run and that's the
app now that
you can actually see here so this is uh
the search bar that we actually had okay
then we had the results we had the
playlist now the results is going to
consist of
a set of tracks which are maintained by
the track list and then you can take
individual tracks with the plus and
minus button and add them into the
playlist okay so that's how
it's typically going to work okay so as
you can view here i'm just going to
search for an artist
and we'll click on the search button it
goes to spotify tries to connect there
and says
that i need to agree to the terms and
conditions
and i've just agreed to that so the very
fact that it actually uh gave us
a confirmation link the moment we tried
to connect and execute our application
uh that's proof enough that it actually
went and connected to the
service there and tried to return a
value to us so this is what we did we
just added an artist we said search
and you can see now it's successfully
connected i've got a list of tracks
available from this artist and you can
see the plus buttons getting added on
the fly so that was the render action
these are
buttons that got added onto this list of
tracks dynamically the moment the search
results returned a value
so i can click on this plus sign and you
can see that the track gets added to the
playlist okay as in when i click here so
i've added a couple of tracks
if i go back to my dashboard of my
musical file application and that i've
created here in the developers portal of
spotify on
developers.spotify.com it's blank so now
i'm going to click on save to spotify
okay and that clears the playlist
so let me come here
and
now when i come out here we saw that it
actually got
successfully connected out here now i'll
have to log in to so this was the
development app that we actually created
on the developers portal of spotify now
we will go to spotify.com
so i'll just go to the spotify website
and it says do you want to launch the
web player and all that so let me click
on that so it just launches
and can you see here this is the new
playlist that just got added right and
there were four songs that i'd actually
added to the playlist and you can see
here those four songs have got added out
here okay so i can go here and
i can delete this playlist and say i
want to delete it okay so there's no
playlist now i'll go back here
i'll add two tracks and i'll say save to
spotify so that's how you actually saw
that the new playlist you can see the
new playlist has come back here okay and
that's the playlist uh the playlist has
got generated again and that's the new
playlist that
got created and we deleted it but it
still got created again and that
indicates the connectivity uh that we
successfully created with this react app
and the core concept of the react app
was breaking it down into components
which is the search component then we
created the track component we created
the track list to maintain a list of
tracks
then we created the search results which
will generate a list of results which
further contains a track list and this
is the embedded iframe which gave us the
response which is scrollable here and
you can see that the iframes we created
allowed us to scroll this
with this embedded web page inside the
iframe container so with that
i hope we've been successful with
explaining the concept of component
based design and architecture with react
and how important it is to create
individual components and the benefit of
that being that you can isolate change
request to a certain component you can
promote reusability wherever you want
the same feature to be implemented on
the page you can just inject that same
component and the same implementation
and the same features can be reused so
it promotes reusability it promotes
flexibility to change it isolates your
change request to single components
preventing the massive effort of
recompiling and retesting the entire
application as a whole in this session
we'll be comparing the three
cutting-edge ui development technologies
that is react.js angular and vue we
learn about the key differences that
make them so distinct all of these
technology stacks have been replacing
pure server-side technologies and we've
slowly progressed from server-side
applications to more distributed
applications where a part of the job is
done on the client side and a part on
the server side and now we've
transitioned to something known as
single page applications or sba and all
of these technologies that you see on
your screen right now are based purely
on javascript as a result they're
lightweight and aren't dependent on any
third-party runtime tools so let's
compare the three technologies and learn
about the factors that make them stand
out so let's see what's in it for you we
learn about their features use cases and
where they're applied their performance
how they handle data the languages they
use and the testing mechanisms we learn
about the dedicated user community that
backs these technologies and finally
we'll see the growth curve first we'll
look into the saline features now react
is a front-end javascript library while
angular and vue are javascript
frameworks now although the terms
library and frameworks are used
interchangeably they're significantly
different now library is a set of
classes or functions and the user is in
complete control to call them frameworks
on the other hand are like models they
have limited choices and come with a
blueprint of their own and as a result
the user doesn't have much control so
javascript being an interpreted language
where code is executed line by line
makes all these tools very efficient
mainly because converting the code into
an intermediate code would require a
runtime environment and would definitely
encounter a delay now these are avoided
and as a result these tools are fast
moving on react is used to develop
mobile and web applications and angular
is used for single page applications and
you can also develop hybrid applications
using the stack mainly because it's
purely based on css html javascript and
jquery single page applications as the
name suggests are built using single
page now the entire page is broken down
into several components wherein each
component performs a specific task say
for example one component handles the
login the other one would display icons
and images and so on all these bits or
components are then put together to form
a single page application and moving on
react was developed and maintained by
facebook while angular was built by
google and vue was developed by evan unx
google employee now react represents the
view part of the mvc framework and
angular is a full-fledged mvc framework
in itself and view on the other hand is
focused on view and the model layer of
the mvc framework now what exactly is
the mvc framework now mvc framework is
an object oriented design principle that
mandates the separation of control
meaning one thing can only do one thing
so the model deals with the entity
classes the data and the business logic
while view deals with the representation
and the ui logic of the application and
the controller drives the functionality
of the two any changes can be easily
factored and isolated and as a result
testing becomes a whole lot easier
moving on now let's look at the use
cases from the business perspective in
terms of react we have top websites like
facebook instagram netflix that use
react on the other hand we have angular
that is used by nike hbo forbes sony and
vue is commonly used by alibaba.com
grammarly 9gag and adobe moving on we
have performance now performance is a
very crucial feature now the moment you
build an html view and render it into
the browser this view to the user is
basically just html tags however if you
look at the internal working the code is
actually converted into a balanced tree
structure this b3 algorithm is extremely
fast so when the user makes any changes
to the ui the changes are reflected
immediately this is facilitated by the
b3 algorithm so as a result the
performance is improved so how does
react make use of this tool it uses a
virtual dom dom is an api developed by
w3c it stands for document object model
and defines how the document is accessed
and manipulated this dom parser converts
the html code into an inverse balance
tree structure so react uses the virtual
dom while angular uses the real dom and
vue uses the virtual dom again now the
virtual dom looks at the differences
between the current and the previous
html pages and only changes the paths
that need to be updated angular on the
other hand updates the entire tree
structure regardless of any changes made
or not and view again only updates the
ones that have changed since there is no
time spent on making unnecessary changes
to the entire tree react is extremely
fast on the other hand real dom updation
is time consuming risky and error pro
vue also ensures faster and bug free
performance now let's talk about data
binding the core reason why we would use
single page applications now consider a
scenario where you log into an
e-commerce website as the user one then
you should be able to see the items in
your shopping cart while user 2 would be
seeing different items in their shopping
carts and so on so identifying the user
and retrieving data corresponding to
that specific user is facilitated using
the help of data binding data binding is
a process that allows an internet user
to manipulate web page elements using a
web browser now it is used in
interactive components such as
calculators tutorials games etc now
react supports one-way data binding
meaning you can take the data from the
view and push it to the model or vice
versa angular on the other hand uses a
two-way data binding while vue also uses
a similar two-way data binding in react
every time the model state updates the
view changes accordingly however the
reverse is not true in case of angular
any changes made to the view are
immediately reflected in the model part
of the architecture view follows the
same principle now this hugely
influences the performance due to
one-way data binding react is modular
and fast improving the performance
angular's two-way data binding adversely
affects the performance and view on the
other hand performs according to the
input type moving on to scripting
languages react combines ui templates
and javascript logic resulting in a new
language called jsx so react only
requires a knowledge of javascript
angular uses templates again in html you
can also inject javascript code into
html using a clever implementation in
angular called directives so you can
create a class and then inject it into
html angular also does something better
you can also write code for an angular
application using a newer language
developed by microsoft called typescript
it is a compiled language and is very
similar to java and c-sharp in terms of
syntax now vue again uses html based
template it uses html5 throughout for
the ui and the combination of javascript
for business logic all view templates
are valid html and can be passed by html
parsers let's move on to testing now
jest is a framework or an api that is
developed by facebook and is used to run
tests on react applications to ensure
that they are bug free now it is
embedded typically in every react
library and requires zero configuration
now angular on the other hand uses the
jasmine framework now this framework
allows various functionalities to write
different kinds of test cases this also
ensures that the application is error
free the view cli or the command line
interpreter has built-in options for
unit testing with the help of jest or
moca now view typically has single file
components and hence these components
can be tested in isolation this makes it
modular and extremely fast now let's
talk about community support since all
these tools are open source they have a
large developer community there are a
few popular github repositories for
react such as react.js 101 react.js.org
and so on you can raise queries solve a
few and connect with the larger
community that's working on react here
are a few repositories for angular view
also has a few popular repositories you
can commit download third party plugins
and also explore these tags even deeper
all of them surely have a very happening
community at the time of writing there
were about 1 million repositories 5
million comments and 1 million issues
with respect to react here are the
figures for angular and here are the
figures for vue according to npm stat
over the past 2 years there have been
approximately 360 million react.js
downloads there have been around 38
million downloads for angular and around
63 million downloads for view now let's
look at the future scope learning a new
technology always comes with questions
like what's in it for me what's its
growth potential how far will it take me
in my career and so on so let's go ahead
and see the growth rate of react angular
and vue according to google trends over
the past 12 months react has been on a
way faster upward trajectory than
angular and vue which have considerably
lost their momentum now this indicates
that react is growing faster than the
other two with respect to popularity
industry adoption and community support
welcome to this session on how to
connect react.js with node.js and in
this session uh we are actually going to
look at
how do we connect react.js with node.js
so a very warm welcome to this session
on react.js connectivity with node.js
and in this session we are going to
focus on how do we connect our react.js
application with the node.js platform so
we are going to dive into creating a
hands-on demo which will have two parts
to it we would have the client
application that we will first create as
a react application we will then create
an express.js application with node.js
and we will then try to connect both of
those applications together so
express.js is a rapid application
development framework that allows us to
create a web application very quickly on
the node.js platform and we'll use it to
create a custom api and then connect
that endpoint to the react.js client
application so let's dive into our demo
and let's start with creating our client
and node express applications and see
how to set them up and then get them
connected to each other let's start with
our hands-on demo and we will first go
to the node.js website nodejs.org we can
download the lts version which is a
stable version of node.js moment i click
on this it will prompt me for a download
it will download the msi file and then
all i need to do is double click on it
keep clicking on the next button and
install that would install node.js for
us next we'll open our editor you can
use any editor of your choice so i'm
going to use
an editor called visual studio code and
let's open up the terminal here and i
also have the command prompt open where
i've navigated to a folder that i've
created called react.js demos now we'll
invoke the npm package manager which is
invoked by the command npx so npx will
not only install packages but also
execute them once they are installed so
once they are downloaded it will execute
the package and
we will use npx to go and create a react
application called client so while we
give it time for the installation to
complete we can then open it within our
editor so we'll give it time
so that the installation completes
so the installation is completed and so
we've seen here that the installation is
now completed and let's
go and open up this project so i will
say file and open folder and
let me pick up that folder and we will
open this application called client so
that's my client app let's fire up
the terminal so
okay so that has launched the terminal
for us
and here uh all we need to do to fire up
this application and get it running is
npm start which will compile and start
up this application that is created
let's close this we'll go to the browser
and now let's say localhost 3000 so that
gives us
a startup page the sample uh default
startup page for the first client
application and this is going to work as
a client we'll now go and try to create
the back-end
application which is going to be another
application that we will set up and to
create that
let's say npx
express
generator api okay so this will uh
create an express application on node.js
called api and let's give it some time
for installation okay so that's done
clear this screen we'll come out here
we'll open another instance of the
editor we'll say open folder and that's
the api application we'll say select
folder and the api application is opened
let's go to the terminal now in the
terminal we will attempt to install all
of the packages that are required that
would be logged in the package.json file
so the package.json file here would be
listed
so you can see we have a list of
packages that it uses and npm install
will go and install all of these
packages that were pre-listed here so
let me ensure it's executed correctly
and we'll fire that once more that's
done so npm install has installed all of
the packages required and let me
terminate this run by pressing a control
c so this terminates
the client application that was
executing and now we will say npm start
so that this application executes and
let's refresh
so that's the standard express
application now that has got installed
now let's go to the api application
we'll go into the bin folder and here
we'll have a file called www we will
change the default port number from 3000
to 9000 let me stop this application
from executing we've just updated the
port number now let's go to the routes
and we'll create a new file in the
routes folder called test api dot js
here we will say variable express
equal to require express
and here we'll say variable router equal
to express dot
router and here we will say
router dot get will open this
so that's the default route root route
is going to be slash for which we'll add
a callback function which will take the
request and the response parameter and
next pointer in case there is another
function to call post that and here we
will just send a simple message saying
api is working okay a simple message
sent out for the root default route and
we'll have to export this so we'll say
module dot exports equal to router all
right so that's uh done let's go to the
app.js file and here let us import that
so here is where we will import this
by saying app.use we want to use the
test api file and that is
test api router and this is exactly the
same variable name that we will declare
here which will be equal to require and
we are going to say routes
test api all right so let's try
launching this now we would say npm
start after adding this code let's go
out here and 3000 test api is going to
be the url to hit it's not 3000 but 9000
now because we just updated the port so
9000 test api and there we have a
message which says that the api is
working properly so this is tested now
let's go to the client application in
the client application let's go to the
app.js file okay this is the file that
we would have to revamp a bit so let's
uh revamp this here we will declare a
class app which extends so that creates
a new module so it extends
react.component
and here we have constructor we will
accept the props here i would pass props
to the super class
constructor and
set the state to api response
currently it just has an empty value
next we'll add up a new function called
call api which will generate a call to
that
api url which was http localhost 9000
was the port and test api was the url
once this is called we will then call
the then function declare response
generate a call to response.txt and then
we will again say this dot set state api
response is going to be equal to the
response that comes in from that url
which is nothing but a string which says
api is working another function called
component will mount so the moment the
component is initialized on the screen
and loaded we will generate a call to
this function we created called call api
then comes
the render function in the render
function we would go and return a div
class name is app this would be app
header the standard logo after which
in the paragraph we wouldn't need the
link here right after the header we'll
add a paragraph where we will print this
dot state and the variable we created
called api response and we will data
bind to that so that largely completes
uh the return so we simply create this
application uh that's the react
application that will talk to this api
that is and this uh url that is hosted
on node communicate with it get a simple
string as a response print that string
inside this
react application so once that's done uh
we have the component wheel mount which
is a life cycle method here it's a life
cycle event that gets triggered the
moment the component loads and that's
when we have actually gone and executed
the call api custom function let's go to
the api application we'll terminate the
execution here there's one more step
that we'll have to perform which is
cross origin
resource sharing which means that to
allow the react application to
communicate from another hosted domain
to this particular domain server we will
actually have to enable cross origin
scripting and sharing otherwise it will
block the request coming from another
application so for that we'll have to
install globally cross origin module and
dash dash save indicates that it's going
to do a global install for all
applications
that are on this particular system so
we've installed this
and we'll clear the screen let's go to
the app.js
and right here is where we would want it
to go and use cards so we will say
app.use course so that it uses this
particular api and here is where we will
declare the course variable and go and
import the new library package that we
just installed which is quartz so looks
good and now let's
fire up this application with an npm
start let's also fire up client with an
npm start and now when i go and
try looking for localhost 3000 which is
the react application the react
application should go and talk to the
api that is hosted on node.js which
returns to me that string message so if
i go and ping that api separately which
is localhost
9000 test api you can see this is a
standard message so here i directly ping
the api that's hosted in node.js now we
are consuming it through the react.js
application and if you scroll down you
can see the message returned from
node.js into react saying the api is
working properly so the practical impact
of this is to actually host restful
services etc on node as a server and you
can go and consume the data that is
written there could be in string text or
json format directly into the react.js
acting as a client application hello
this is matthew with simply learn and
today we're going to cover react with
redux
so with our session today we're going to
go through it's going to cover why you'd
want to use redux when you're building a
react solution what redux is what are
the core principles of redux and what
are those pillars that drive what you're
doing redux and then finally what are
the pros and cons of redux and after
we've gone through the powerpoint
presentation here what we're going to do
is we're actually going to go through
and actually do a demo of actually using
uh redux so you can actually see how
this would all look so why would you use
redux well the reason why you want to
use redux is that redux actually
understands and helps manage the state
of an object
and redux was introduced to help address
some problems that you're having with
react so the state for an object stores
values and properties that belong to
components that could potentially change
over time so
the state could be modified by actions
in your network uh they could be
changes to the re-render of the
component in the browser and the object
could also then
potentially store multiple properties
and then with redux it actually takes in
and actually will create a uh you know
take a
large application that you could create
with app with a react and breaks it down
to several components instead of having
this massive number of states you have
to manage and so every time that you you
know an application will then switch
from a current with a react you'd
actually be then changing the states and
this is a really big problem because
when you're like doing that switching
back and forth there is the potential
for applications to be re-rendered which
reduces the efficiency of your
application and so this is why redux was
introduced
so you know what is redux so redux is a
way to be able to have a predictable
state container for your javascript
applications and allow you to run your
applications in multiple different
environments so whether it's a client
solution a service solution or a native
app solution and then more importantly
or one of the key
elements that i like about redux is that
it's really easy to test and so with
redux you're able to manage the state of
your tool
you can actually use it to work with any
javascript framework or library and you
can actually then store the um the
application and the components in a
state store which makes it easy to be
able to manage the state of your
application so in simple words redux
stores all the state objects in a single
store and organizes it it provides
information about the current state of
the application any changes in the state
the application can be described to the
store by the user and then it notifies
any modifications made to the state of
that application so let's jump into the
key principles of redux and there's
three key areas i want to focus in so
the first one is that redux provides a
single source of truth um and that's our
source of truth is uh being able to
store the state of your whole
application in an object tree in a
single store and this makes it easier
for you to debug and inspect uh
components of your application uh also
enables you to be able to persist your
app stage for development and improve
faster development cycles the second
principle is its state is read only and
that's why you're able to
describe more effectively what's
happening because it is read only and
this ensures that no events like network
callbacks
would
create and any issues with the code and
the re-rendering of your application
and that object actions are become then
just plain objects and then finally
changes are made with pure functions and
so what do we mean by this so we can
actually
take actions and transform the state
tree with pure reducers and we'll go
into a demo electron to show you this
but a reducer is essentially a function
that accepts an accumulation value and
then it takes back and returns that as a
new accumulation and this allows you to
have a single source of truth value the
user can return the new state objects
instead of mutating to previous state
uh the user can
start with a single reducing as the app
grows it can then split off into a
smaller reducers
and then finally the reducers just
become functions so let's talk about the
pillars of redux
and so there are three key areas we have
the store the actions and then reduces
and then the store itself is the actual
main object that holds the application
tree state
and there are four key
states there's get state which returns
the current c to the store and when we
actually run the demo later on you'll be
able to see that we'll be able to open
up our terminal window and be able to
get the state store from our terminal
window
the second state is dispatch and this is
a an action it's the only way to update
the application state and here we have a
action on a button change to actually
change the state of the application and
then the final two are subscribe
unsubscribe
and these are our ways in which you can
actually change the listener to the
state so an action is a plain object
that represents an intention to change
the state so with actions you have
payloads of information that send data
back and forth to your application store
so you can send any kind of data and
they can go back and forth and that
actions must also have been a tight
field that indicates the type of action
that has been performed then finally
with reducers reducers are
specified how the application state
changes in response to actions sent to
the store and so actions only describe
what's happened but don't describe the
application state change
they are a reducer is a function that
accepts the current state and an action
and then returns a new state with the
action performed and then finally you
can use combined reducers utility which
can then combine reduces in an app into
a single a index
so let's look at the pros and cons of
using redux because nothing is
perfect so a pro for working with redux
is that
redux provides a single source of truth
which is the store so there's no
confusion over where you're getting your
values
this then leads to having a predictable
and strict outcome redux is more
stringent about how the code is
organized this makes it easier to
onboard developers because there is a
very structured way of writing redux
code this makes it also then
easier for the initial render which
allows you to make uh your solution
really optimized as an experience and
then finally developers can track
everything that's going on inside the
app in real time the cons so
one of the big cons is there's no
encapsulation so you're using redux to
test out the code and the writing of
your code
but
the component cells can access data and
they there is potential for security
issues
you do have to use boilerplate code so
this kind of takes us back to the
structured code format it is um strict
in its setup and it is memory intensive
so with that let's go in and look at a
demo of using redux to
reformat a react application
so in this demo we're going to use react
to show how redux can work first thing
we want to do is go ahead and download
node.js we're going to go to nodejs.org
to get the latest download the downloads
are available in windows mac os and
linux you can also download and
recompile the source code if you want
i encourage you to go with the latest
lts version it's the latest stable
version now there are other versions you
can use but that's one you would want to
use i already have it installed so i
just want to show you how that looks so
i'm just going to go in and put node
version it's going to give me the
version number so that shows that it's
installed and we'll also use npm which
is node package manager because we'll be
using that validate that it's installed
by doing node mpm-version
okay so looking good and we're gonna go
ahead and create a folder um on our
desktop um normally you wouldn't put
a project folder on your desktop but you
know this is just for an experiment so
we're gonna call this one
redux react is going to be taking a
react project and we're going to show
what it looks like as a standard project
and then what it will look like
as a project that's being uh taken
through redux
so let's just move our cursor to the
correct folder
and so we're going to go to cd redux
react
and there we are we're in at the correct
folder using our command prompt
you use terminal on mac os
so let's just type in mpx and that's for
our redax and we're going to do create
dash react dash app so we're going to
create a default react app and then
we'll also install redux dash app
and these are the two
components that we need to be able to
build out our solution one is react and
it's react js
and the second is redux and we hit
return and this is going to go ahead and
download the latest versions of both of
these applications and install them into
the folder that we just created on our
desktop
just give that a moment
and so it's installing the different
packages react react dom
react scripts
and there we are have everything
installed great
and these are just different commands
you can use
and it's recommending that we select npm
start
to get everything up and running so we
use visual studio code to do most of our
work here vs code
is open source solution for scripting
and it's available on all leading
platforms it is from microsoft but it is
open source and
there's just a ton of stuff here but
we're going to go ahead and we're going
to open up the folder we just created on
our desktop
and so here is redux react
app and we're going to select that
folder
and on the
left hand side you'll see all the files
from that folder which is getting rid of
the welcome screen we don't need that
anymore uh you'll see there's some
commands we can use we do
control plus
i'm not sure what that's called again
anyway it gets us to the terminal window
um
not an exclamation point
so you'll see that in our project folder
we have all of the files we need for our
solution we have both the node modules
and then the public files the product
files is just the application itself so
over here on the index.html you see the
index file there and we're going to
actually show what this looks like
inside of
as it's broadcast from a web browser in
a moment now uh we're going to create a
very simple application here um and the
application is going to look exactly the
same in both um
just standard react and redux react it's
the optimization that's going to be
improved so we just did mpm dash and
start it's going to take us to local
host call on 3000 give it a moment and
then we should get our
floating
logo showing that the application's up
and running up there we are
we can go ahead and head and edit app.js
to
create our application
okay so let's go in and we're going to
go into app.js
and we are going to create an
application called
newcomp.js
and we actually have some code that
we've already created that you can
download as part of this application
so but we're just going to type in here
import react
and then component
from
[Music]
react
so i'm going to pull in our react
library
and we also import
connect
from
react
redux
and that's the
package that we're working in
let's
terminate the batch job yes
and then rerun
npm
install
save
react
dash redux
and here we go takes a moment just to
install that
so our goal here is to show
how you can optimize your solution with
redux for the
using the store and reduces in redux
again
the solution is going to look exactly
the same what's going to change is the
performance of the solution
and this is what redux gives you all
right so we're going to go ahead and
we're going to go in i'm going to type
in class
new comp
extends component
and then we're just going to select our
constructor
props
and then we want to add in the
super props
and then this
state
equals
i have a message here
subscribe
to simply learn
very simple little app don't forget to
save your work as you go along
and we're just going to apply some
styles
let's just make the
apply some font style
like italics
then we're gonna
make the color
purple
and let's have a button that we're going
to press a
button change
equals
this set state
oh sorry get state
and we'll have a message that comes up
basically saying thank you for
subscribing
there we go we have our button we'll
change the state here in a moment
and very simple
little application
now we want to rent that
on the screen
i just have some basic
html for where we're going to place
everything we use div tag
for our app
again we're going to keep this really
simple
and we're going to call
reference this styles for
this h3 tag
so our message is gonna be subscribe to
simply learn
this will be create dynamically gonna
use our style
i'm gonna add in a button
click
action
subscribe
and nope change too many s's
right we'll save that
all right save now let's run
a script
you guys have js
and we can actually import that into
our app.js script
and we'll extend
the newscorp js
component into here
apparent
font style here
and
render this correctly
and i'll pull in the text
and styles
again it's pretty simple little
application
now playing from use code
so we'll actually have
a welcome screen a welcome line and then
pulling the two lines of code
all right let's
run that
npm start
and here we go
refreshes our page
so what we've just created is a basic
standard state object
and
let's see now oh yeah this is good now
we actually can show you that we didn't
actually write all our code correctly so
let's go back and fix that
it's newport and use
newscomp.js and we have to make sure
that we
have a correct export feature here so
that the image that the everything can
be exported effectively and import we
also need to have an export
all right let's run that again
okay should take care of our
uh problem hey there we are so welcome
and then we have the standard state
object of subscribe to simply like hit
subscribe and we change the text to
thank you for subscribing okay so let's
kind of go in and modify this now so it
goes from being a standard state object
to one that uses store and reduces
so we're going to go ahead and terminate
our batch job
and essentially reset everything
and what we're going to do now is
install redux
this is what's going to help us
it takes a moment to install redux
all right so we have redux installed
that's good
and now we want to
start
our package
and it looks the same but now we're
going to make some changes
so let's go to
our index file
index.js
here's our react dom
now we're going to add in
contour
so this is going to be our react this is
going to be our redux store so we're
going to create a new store
now it's going to be a reducer
and
we're going to
put in
strict mode
okay juice is not too fine let's go
ahead and define that
so
we're going to come over
to our new comp
js file
and what we want to do here is we're
going to
take out the one class file that we just
created
and
i'm just gonna stripping it down here
now let's go in
and
let's map our state
to
[Music]
props equals
state
and we're going to do return
message
is state dot message
and then
[Music]
construct map dispatcher props
and this is going to be our dispatch
and we're going to
return
and we have our button
change
for dispatch
we'll type in what the message is
now we have message change
let's turn from the button okay
so we'll pass the value over
all right
and now we actually
connect
as part of our export and in our
connection i'm going to do map state
props
and map
dispatch props
all right now we're going to go in and
it's going to be for our new comp
now we want to switch over
and we're going to just change
some of our linking variables here
so serve to button change we're going to
do props dot button change
otherwise we won't be able to find in
our code
this is some pathing
and
[Music]
you go ahead and create a new folder and
this one is going to be our store
and again this is going to be our redux
store
we're going to call the store
reducer.js
and
const
initial state equals
this is what the default state will be
for when the page loads which will be
subscribed to simplyland
and then
the reducer
we're going to place to where the
reducer is
and constant new state
and it's going to be
an if action
dot type
i'm going to change the message
there's unused comp
so that's the
action there we
pull that
so it's identical
and then new state dot message
equals
thank you for subscribing so
we have the default and now we have the
new message
yeah this might seem like um extra work
but actually makes your
whole application much more efficient
export default
reducer
all right so make sure we saved all our
files which we have
and
now let's go ahead
so we have let's just inspect everything
it's all looking good
all right
now terminal window we're going to do
npm start and see what happens
and our web browser should load up
oh we have an error
that's good so now we're learning stuff
so this is again this is all part of
your standard coding is just hunting
down errors in your code so let's go to
index.js
and
looks like
we're going to pull in here
so we have reduce and this should
actually be
spelled correctly there we go
okay all right everything is now
as it should be
let's go back
recompile
let's
rerun uh
file
and do we want to move our file let's
just go ahead and move the store
i'm going to update all the links to the
store
and we're going to be trying mainstream
provider store
is referenced correctly
okay let's rewrite our application
and
there we are
so let's go back through
our applications running much faster now
we're able to manage our changes and
elements for our applications different
objects
we're able to change the messages after
you click
and it's able to then create the new
message again this is a very simple
application but you can see how for more
complex solutions how this become useful
and you can start using the different
components you create
for your whole solution
and that's our demo
welcome to this session on react native
versus flutter in this session we would
look at identifying some of the
differences between the react native and
flutter frameworks let's start with
understanding the core areas of
comparison as part of this session we
will be looking at key aspects to
identify differences between both the
frameworks predominantly on the language
front the ui aspect the performance the
documentation the popularity the
community support that is available for
both these frameworks along with the
industry trends
in terms of the industry adoption for
both these platforms the core objective
of the session would be that at the end
you should be able to decide and make an
informed decision as to which framework
is the best among those available let's
start from a language perspective now if
you look at react react is basically
completely written and built in
javascript using the react.js api on the
other hand if you look at flutter it is
basically written in a very new language
called as start and we do not have uh
too many developers that are skilled on
dart however uh every browser and every
platform being shipped with uh
inbuilt javascript execution environment
that makes javascript platform the
language of choice
for developers so every browser today or
every browser manufacturer would have
inbuilt support for executing javascript
programs similarly most popular
platforms mobility platforms like
android and ios have default support for
executing javascript programs and that's
the reason when you compare this with
flutter flutter uses dart which is
predominantly a newer language and we
really do not have too many developers
who are skilled on this so actually is
the selling point
and the usb of react native because when
you work with react native uh you really
do not have to relearn a lot you don't
have a sharp learning curve most of the
javascript developers who are working
with means tag already working with html
css and dhtml can easily align to this
that as we have discussed
is pretty new in the industry and would
not have that much of penetration in the
developer community from a ui
perspective when you talk about react
native it's based pretty much on native
components for the android and the ios
platform and flutter on the other hand
uses a very proprietary
set of widgets and it has its own page
structure that needs to be set up so
it's a closed ecosystem as compared to
an open ecosystem in react native which
allows you to go and implement
third-party widgets and ui frameworks as
well now this is really what allows you
to pick and choose with react native
because you can go and decide whether
you want to use kendo ui or a set of
generic controls or any other third
party ui framework can be implemented
but for flutter you have a pretty closed
ecosystem and that's the reason the ui
components that are available out of the
box and built into the platform are all
that you can use from a performance
perspective when you talk about react
native it basically
is built and uses javascript out of the
box and that's the reason when you want
to write any code in javascript that
connects and tries to access native
services on that specific platform it
uses a bridge to do that but when you're
using flutter on the other hand flutter
does not need any kind of bridge so
there's no concept of you write flutter
code and then it uses a bridge to go and
connect to the native set of components
to interact with and this is what really
impacts the speed and the performance
aspect of developing and executing
applications between both these
frameworks because if you look at react
the speed of development is a little bit
slower when you compare that with
flutter and that's because it has an
intermediate bridge that it has to
communicate with and every layer of
additional communication and computation
that you put in between two tiers in a
application that you built obviously
would have a performance impact from a
documentation perspective if we were to
compare flutter typically has a very
well defined
documentation repository and it allows
developers to go through it in a very
simple manner so it's all structured
it's all organized unlike what you see
on react native because in react native
it actually since react native is an
open ecosystem and allows you to
implement third party widgets and you
can do a lot of configuration and plug
and play and that's the reason uh the
documentation also is not very strong
well organized and impactful and that's
the reason uh most developers would find
it a little challenging to go through
the react native documentation when you
compare that to the documentation
available in terms of flutter popularity
is always a key when working with
platforms and that should be a crucial
decision maker because when it comes to
open source technologies and you're
stuck somewhere you obviously go to the
commit to the community to go and find
out how best you can solution the
problem now flutter being relatively a
new entrant into the market it does not
have a lot of developer penetration and
that's the reason the popularity in the
community is not very strong react
natively there for a while now it's been
around for some time and that's the
reason uh it's pretty popular among
developers also since uh it uses
javascript it's a natural transition and
a progression path for those who are
working with html5 css building web
applications or have been building
hybrid mobile apps find it very easy to
migrate to this because flutter requires
you to learn a new programming language
which is start and that is one more
reason why the popularity of this is
much much better on the react native
front as compared to flutter again if
you look at google trends
you could actually look at both of the
lines here the red line indicating
flutter it started on a very positive
note and then there was a plateau and
then suddenly a spike react native has
been much more steady in terms of its
growth and ultimately if you look at it
now both of them seem to be trending at
par with each other so the community
support as we were speaking about if you
look at stack overflow which is one of
the most popular websites to go for any
kind of uh developer
trends and movements and for a q a that
most developers would have you can
actually look at the number of questions
here and uh also
react native is part of uh github as its
open source it was released in 2015 and
uh it's because of the huge community
support that it becomes uh easier to
implement this you have a lot of
confidence as a developer when you start
building on this stack uh because if
you're stuck somewhere you will have a
lot of help available on the way on the
other hand if you compare that with
flutter you can look at the question
count here on stack overflow and this
being a new entrant in the market
it has a smaller footprint on the
community aspect but of course that
keeps increasing every day again from a
react native perspective and you talk
about stability in terms of stable
releases uh there again you would see
that react native does a much better job
as compared to flutter so the industry
tents are something which all of us have
to be aware of specifically if
we would need to make a decision in
terms of our careers the technology that
we are learning what is the growth
aspect what is the industry adoption and
how we could really move ahead on our
career graphs in terms of the
opportunities market the job market etc
so again getting back to stack overflow
which is the benchmark for understanding
technology trends in ide sphere and
software development if you look at a
recent survey conducted in 2019 uh 62.5
percent of developers uh seem to have
shown interest in react native as
compared to a marginal rise of 65.4
percent where flutter seems to be doing
much better and of course that could be
due to the uh time frames that uh both
these technologies uh have been around
react has been around for quite a while
and hence the job prospects are much
better a lot of organizations
implementing this clutter has been a new
entrant and hence
slightly fewer opportunities as the
penetration still needs to happen in the
opportunities job market and
from a developer skills perspective so
these are some of the big names that are
using react native india implementations
right from facebook to pinterest to wix
skype tesla insta bloomberg uh you can
actually look at
the implementation across industry which
is absolutely crucial when you're
learning something new because when you
want to join a large logo obviously if
there are a lot of logos using this that
enhances the credibility of your
learning puts a justification to why you
would want to learn this technology
flutter on the other hand associated
with big names like google sonos alibaba
the largest retailer out there from a
conclusion perspective if we were to
conclude on what we've discussed from a
language perspective obviously we said
react is much more popular since it is a
natural progression for developers to
work on javascript and move to this as
compared to dart which is relatively a
new language from a ui perspective the
open source plug-and-play capability of
configuring and adopting seamlessly to
newer platforms of widgets and
third-party ui platforms are much better
as compared to flutter which is a closed
ecosystem and depends on inbuilt widgets
to implement the performance aspect we
discussed because of the bridge from the
code that you write to the native
component access exists in react and is
isolated and not any longer required in
flutter and hence the performance is
impacted because of the additional layer
in between the documentation much much
better in flutter because it's a closed
ecosystem and they can control what you
can use react native being open-ended it
really has a lot of third-party
integration you can do and hence the
documentation is not really well
organized the popularity perspective
react native much more popular among
html5 css three mer mean stack
developers since it's all javascript
flutter needs you to learn new skills
and you need to spend additional time
for that from a community support react
native has been there for a longer time
as compared to flutter and hence has a
stronger community support as compared
to flutter and that translates into
better job prospects in the industry for
react native as compared to flutter so
if we were to give it a score react
scores much better with a total score of
five leaving flutter with a total score
of two so i hope we were able to
understand the differences between the
react native and flutter and this will
help you make better decisions with
planning your career and deciding which
technology you should latch on
so our demo is going to be about
creating a calculator using react and
node.js and so we have here just a basic
calculator nothing crazy um but the
whole thing is going to be created with
react and so be using javascript to be
installing react and installing the
various components such as node.js and
the different npm solutions that we need
so as you can see the calculator works
just fine and now let's go ahead and
let's go and install the different tools
that we need so the first one is going
to be node.js
and we do google search on node.js we
always start with google searches
because it's the easiest way to find
things and so we go to the default
node.js site and you can go to downloads
and there are windows mac os and also
linux installers you can also download
the original source code and compile it
yourself if you want and you'll also
need a text editor i'm going to be using
visual studio code it's just my favorite
text editor it's free works across all
platforms uh it comes with a ton of
extensions so you can get up and running
really quickly with it
um so we're just going to go ahead and
install the windows version i already
have installed so i don't have to
download it again you also want to make
sure that you have the latest version of
node.js installed now with that node
package manager so we're just going to
open up our terminal window and validate
which version that we have
running and we can do that fairly easily
we can
just put in node
version and it will tell us which
version and which means that's installed
and same thing with npm
node package manager we'll do npm
version and that will give us back the
version number again you have to have
them installed for them to be able to uh
do that and we're gonna also now create
a react app so we're gonna do install
and then it's going to be create dash
react app that's the command to create a
new react app
and we're going to install it right off
our desktop
so let's go in and we'll put mpx
create dash react dash app
and then the app is going to be called
calculator which will install a folder
on our desktop with all the appropriate
react code
and this will be just a template
application but it'll have everything
there that we need to get started with
hit return and
that will take a few minutes just to
install everything
and here we go
and so as we go through some of the
components that we're going to be
creating today we're going to be
creating an app component and they'll be
the main component that has all the
information that will then be disabled
on the screen then we have a layout
component and that will be the actual
look and feel of the calculator and the
output component which will be the
results from the calculator and then the
output row and this will be all the
different tools that we will need and
here we have
our new folder right there
on our desktop um but we're actually
going to go now into visual studio and
if you've seen any of the other
node.js videos that we've created you
know that i like to work with the
node.js in visual studio code um because
i can run terminal window right there so
i'm going to open up the folder that we
just created that's called calculator i
want to open up a whole folder
not a file but the whole folder
and here's our folder on the left hand
side
we have all the different files there's
our json package that has the
instructions for what the calculator
looks like
including which version of react and the
dom
and here's our default
uh element
as you can see because we're using react
it's going to embed the code into a html
page and so we have a div with the id of
root that's going to reference um some
class files that we create and so the
app.js file
has the application code that we're
going to be modifying in a little bit
and you'll see that it actually then
references up to
our
index.js file
and if in index.js file it has the id
element root which ties back to
the id element of root in our html file
so we're constantly referencing and
cross-referencing our application
and this is where we're going to be
doing most of our work
right so we're going to go ahead and
open up the terminal window
and the first thing we want to do is
start
uh npm
and
it's now going to have everything
running on let's have localhost and
everything running on port 3001
we'll give that a moment and this will
actually then
bring up just the standard default react
boilerplate app
it's just taking a moment to load
i should probably get a faster computer
okay there we are
uh just not patient so here we have our
basic boilerplate react js application
nothing to create crazy here
so let's actually go in and start
working in some of our code so uh see
now yep everything's running where we
expect it to run
all right so let's go into fjs
and
we can actually go ahead and if you want
to type control plus c and actually stop
the app or you can um
uh in the terminal window you can
actually stop it
now you can also go up into the terminal
command to stop it as well
and if we do stop the app then we'll get
an error message there we go
site can't be reached
and you'd expect this
we go back in
and
we're going to just restart
our application
everything should now be working just
fine
we're going to refresh the page
and we'll see
our default react app
coming up on port 3001
and there we are
looking good looking good
okay so we're going to delete out what
we have there because we want to put in
our own content
and we're going to call this one class
app and we're going to go in and we're
going to be modifying that class here in
just a moment
i'm putting a default layout
i'm going to create a new folder
this folder is going to be called
components this is going to be for our
calculator
and put a new file in there
i'm going to call this one layout.js
and this is where we're going to start
breaking down the structure of our
layout
and we're going to
say import
layout
and then we want to do the path to our
components
layout you need so we have the dot
because we have to go up one folder
that's the command for that
so dot up one folder components folder
layout
notice we don't have to type layout.js
it automatically knows
to add the js extension
constantly making sure that we're saving
let's go over to layout.js
and this is our layout
do this using css
then we're going to import
react
from
and then select import
and then we're going to link to layout
css it's going to be a css file that
we're going to create
so we have to type that into layout.css
and notice we had to write out
explicitly that it's a css file
and so
here we have
and then we're going to put in
the constructions for the layout
what our props look like
and then we'll export default layout so
it can
show up correctly
okay so we go to our web page now
yep that's good we're expecting to see
that so we need to
change some of our pathing here just
quite quickly
so
let's see
[Music]
we're going to move a file so it can be
accessed appropriately
we run this
you know what i think we didn't we have
to update
um yep i know we have to go back to
layout and
we have to start adding in
some values here
so that
the application knows to lay content out
so we just put in
a
hello world
there we go okay so that shows us that
everything is pulling through correctly
so we want to get rid of hello because
we're going to replace that with our own
application
i'm going to change this
div so that actually starts
pulling in the application
and i'm going to put in the class name
for calculator
and this will be a css reference
okay
so you
need to have some image files
and what we're doing here is we're
essentially building up the
different elements that will need to be
presented on the screen
and then we'll have a
css file that we'll use to create these
elements
and as you can imagine i've i've already
got this written so i'm cheating a
little bit because i know what i'm
putting here
but uh as bottom line is that the
calculator really is a bunch of form
elements
such as buttons
on the screen but we use css to reformat
them so it looks more like a traditional
calculator
that's one of the the things that you
get comfortable working with when you're
doing web applications is how to take
technologies that you're used to using
and then modifying them so that they
look different and so in this instance
we're used to using button elements
within an application so
why not use the the same button elements
which consistently work from browser to
browser
and then just simply
update the look and feel of them with
some css so that
they they look good
and here we are just doing a very simple
on click command
um this is some basic
javascript that will render inside of
the browser itself
okay so now we see boom there's a button
all right so and again you want to be
constantly testing and verifying that
the code you're writing is working
correctly
and we're going to do
another button
and this is going to be the delete
button
so we've got we're going to start
building out our different buttons here
so let's delete
now we have an unclick event for that
okay we're just doing some formatting
here
okay so we just used
going through our code here
making sure everything looks good
and one of the things we can now do
because we've got a base line
that looks correct we can just copy that
and then we want the percentage sign and
then the forward bracket so this
so it gives us our two buttons so we
have a
new row here
i'm just gonna copy everything over just
make it a little bit easier ourselves
and then we're just going to pipe in the
numbers
7 8
and then
plus symbol sorry the multiply symbol
and we'll be able to move these into
multiple rows here in just a moment
and we just want to keep
going through making all the changes
here so we actually fill out all the
different elements
so as you can see most of this
isn't really
complex it's
just the
uh you use the word fiddly yeah i guess
again the the fiddly parts of
putting this content together
so we refresh our screen we start seeing
all the different elements
okay looking good
we'll have to come back and make some
updates
to
our css class names
and then we do our final three buttons
across the bottom
now
[Music]
okay so let's now add some styles to the
content that we've created
we do that in our layout.css file
and so we already have some styles that
we created so we're just going to go
ahead
and for the
for the sake of brevity we're just going
to pull those over
um
we can
if you want to and have us do a more
detailed video on how to
create the csc css files and
you know we'll certainly do that but i
think most you probably know how to do
this already
all right so here's our css file and so
we have our calculator keys our buttons
and the different types of button here
so we can just copy these all over and
so these these will have the background
color the watercolor et cetera et cetera
and so i'm going to do that
here we have our
buttons
for our app
easy way you know how
okay so we take out the css then we just
have basic buttons
we have the css link back in
we have
nice laid out application
so we've got a couple of areas that are
still missing we've got the results
screen and the
default logo so
let's go ahead and add that information
in
and we'll create a new folder called
assets and the assets will put
another folder called font
and that'll be where our fonts will be
then we'll create another folder we'll
call this one images
and we'll put our images in there
so we have our logo image just simply
learn logo
and then for layout we can then
just reference that in our image
reference
i'm going to import the logo
i'm going to import that from
our assets folder
and under assets we'll go to amg which
we have our image
and then we'll do the path for the
logo.png
so remove this
and then we'll do source
and we'll do the source is
from
our logo variable which is the as the
import of the image
i'll put the width
and we have to know it's 150 pixels and
the
there we go 150 pixels wide
and the style that will reference from
css
will be
block
so just some inline styling here
don't generally normally do this i
normally have all my styling in my css
folder um but uh in this instance
because we're just putting up a solution
i want you to be able to see that you
can actually do this in line so there we
are however that logo
okay so now we need to have the
results screen make sure that looks
correct
okay
and so we're going to create a new
folder and this is going to go to our
output
js file and this is going to control the
output of that blue screen
and put our react objects
and we'll export that
and we'll put a new file called output
row
dot js
we'll put our instructions
this is going to be our component the
users will put their
results into
and
now put row
[Music]
and we're gonna
put our instructions here so we're gonna
like export
default
output row
all right so we're going to start
putting together the code that allows us
to construct
our solution
and we're going to update the output
row.js file
and
we're going to
add in our return value
so i'll put a div
and this will be
input type
so essentially we have a text field um
that will be read only at the top of our
calculator and here we see our text
field here
and
that will allow us to be able to
put in our values
and we use the class screen that allows
us to give our formatting
and we're going to put
a file it's going to be output row.css
we're going to add in our specific css
for
this output row
and as you can see we're just using all
of our standard html5
skill sets here
and let's go over to our
style it
will pull in our
props dot text size
and then the default
value
and so this is going to align with uh
go over to our css file and we'll update
that
output.js
make sure the results get returned
correctly
as we're tapping on the buttons
and so this will
pull in our output row
and the value will be
[Music]
we bring our text size for output flow
here
[Music]
and we're just going to put some
sample css styling here
nothing too crazy
and we have two
rows
save that
our two rows will appear in a moment
let's go into our layout
let's add in our rows
so this is our output i'm gonna
pull in those values
and there we have our two values
and so we can apply some css styling to
this
so the top row will be
the calculation broken out as we've
written it and the bottom row will be
the results
it's going to our css file here we're
going to copy over some css
and you have some
font styling
we have our screen class name
there's our screen here
again this is
nothing no rocket science here and we've
done any css
um editing you'll be familiar with what
we've done here
you see they're referring to a font
asset we actually have the font in there
to
pull that font over
and and
it's just a ttf font true type font
now you can use and any of the uh
internet fonts as well google has a
massive library
of fonts
and there we are
i'm going to change the size of our
font so that the second row the text is
a little bit bigger
a little bit smaller and we don't have
anything wired up yet we'll do that in a
moment that'll be the
easy part of this assignment
all right so let's go over and
now layout
okay so net
input
set input
and use state
that we can default the initial state
and for the result
the you state
the initial usage will be just blank
there we are
just what you'd expect to see
so the results
um
blank and this is just when you run the
app for the very first time
okay so going through
and now we want to put in our actions so
we can have an event
when we click on any of the buttons
you want to take the value of the button
and
so this
you're going to be
any of these actions here
and
we're just going to put together a
script to do the calculations
so as you can see so far
we've put most of this application
most of the hard work has been setting
up the base react application
putting together the
different files and folder structure
making sure we have the correct assets
such as
images
fonts
uh
css files
laying out our core structure in
form elements
and now
the part that we're doing at the end
here
is putting together the script that will
actually write
that actually do our calculator
events and and honestly and this is
going to be um
i've got this running here it's just
javascript so there are lots of
javascript calculators on the internet
so you can actually take any of those
and use those as a base
for what we're doing here
there we have it if there's an error
we'll do math error result
we don't expect to see that
and we'll just keep putting together our
code here
there are different results
so depending on
[Music]
which commands you use so for instance
with the equal sign
and
have the results
so we're using the value to actually
then trigger
what we would actually be
seeing in which screen
okay it's looking good
so we'll capture our value and
this is all concatenate together
and
if there are any error messages
so if the value is
c from the button so if we set c
so we want to set the input to zero
which is to reset
the screen
and
[Music]
if the value
equals
and this will be delete
what we want to do is we want to
manipulate the string on the screen
which means we're going to
[Music]
eliminate
the last character entered
and this is
manipulation here
and this is all reducing the length of
the string
by one character at a time
again this is your standard
javascript control
so we hit delete
and that gets rid of a character another
character hit it again i'll get rid of
the third character
and
put if the string is
zero then put
that as the value
all right
this allows us to test out our
application
all looking good so far
okay
i want to make sure that we're then
calculating our values correctly
and here we have
the
display and the input
it's all coming from here our output
class
put in our results
okay it looks like we're letting lining
everything up just always want to go
back and double check that you have all
your commands all your variables lining
up
correctly
eliminate those
we'll make sure we have the answer
and the user entered there
and we have the answer in the user and
we'll change the font size
you say that
we go over this is now this is our local
application
and we test it we can start putting
together our construct
and we'll see that our calculator is
working so clear gets rid of both values
everything's looking pretty good
and here we have our first application
and this is the sample application
this is the application we just wrote
here is the original application that we
were testing against
and as you can see
everything lined up correctly
and so you've seen how in just 45
minutes you can actually
write out your own
react js application with node.js
and so we terminate the application
so this is the one we just built
it's going to fail so that
allows us to validate that we actually
created we'll restart the services
say yes
i'm running on another porch because we
already have an app running on
another port it says run on
refreshing the web page
and voila there we are there's our
application up and running
everything looks really good
working fine
it works absolutely identically
now if you want to you could actually
then take this application and
make it a native application as well
right now just using as a web
application
we're just updating some of the css
making it a little bit tighter
everything looking exactly the same
there you go that's your app
all up and running welcome to the
session on react.js interview questions
through this session we will explore the
most commonly posed interview questions
that you would face if you walk up to a
developer interview on react.js let's
start with going through and exploring
the general set of react.js interview
questions that would be commonly asked
in an interview the first question would
be what are the features of react.js now
right through this session we would
follow a common methodology where we
would explore the question and then look
at the best way in which you could have
answered that question if posed to you
during a react.js interview so starting
with the first question what are the
features of react so react has many
extensions for complete application
architecture support jsx is used with
react to describe what the user
interface should typically look like
react is broken into small components so
you look at the complete application you
want to build break it down into
individual components and a component is
typically a piece of user interface like
a function that would return a stream of
html characters speedy performance is
one of the core features of react as
only the updated components need to be
re-rendered on the screen and not the
entire page the one-way data binding
feature on the other hand keeps
everything modular and fast the virtual
dom is also a lightweight representation
of the real dom which is again a feature
with helps speed up performance and
avoids a full page refresh and a full
dom tree shake which really speeds up
performance so what is jsx how do you
answer this so jsx is typically the
extension used for react and it's
nothing but an extension to the
javascript programming language because
all that you can use inside your browser
for execution typically has to be
javascript because in html5 you cannot
have any third-party plugins installed
in the browser and that's the reason the
browser would only ship by default with
a javascript runtime engine so by using
jsx you can write html structures in the
same file that would contain your
javascript code as well making the
updates to the code very simple so it's
simple to update and make modifications
to your code because the code and the
data and the business logic is all
composed in a single file so because the
code and the business logic is in a
single file it makes
updating and incorporating change
requests
to the code very simple and easy so it's
basically used with react to describe
what your user interface should look
like and it's what you typically would
term as the html template or the view
coming to the next question can jsx be
directly read by the web browser so web
browsers cannot read jsx directly now
why is that well the reason is simple
it's because they are only built to read
regular javascript objects and jsx is
not a regular javascript objects it's a
react component so for a web browser to
read a jsx file the file needs to be
transformed into a regular javascript
object and for this there is a
javascript api called people which is
internally used by react so what do you
understand by the virtual dom that we've
been speaking about in react so react
gives a very lightweight representation
of the real dom the actual dom structure
of the page so dom is document object
model it is an api created by w3c and it
creates an in-memory representation of
the html elements as an inverted tree
structure a balanced tree structure
which is the fastest search algorithm
when you want to search for html
elements and do a dynamic update on them
but again updating the basic tom tree
structure of the page causes a full page
refresh and if you only want to update a
specific component you wouldn't need the
entire page to be refreshed and that is
where react comes in it uses a virtual
dom which is a layer on top of the
actual dom which ensures that only a
certain part of the page is refreshed
and that speeds up performance so when
the state of an object changes virtual
dom changes only that object in the real
dom instead of updating all the objects
and this is what makes things really
fast so why use react instead of other
frameworks like angular first of all
it's very easy to create dynamic web
pages dhtml where you can update the
view or the template at runtime the
components are reusable so you reuse
rather than reinvent the performance is
great since you're working with the
virtual dom you don't need a full page
refresh the unidirectional data flow
makes data move one way there's no
two-way data binding by default and
that's the reason the page does not have
to do a lot of heavy lifting of
remembering whether the view is changing
whether the the base javascript entity
class is changing and that saves a lot
of uh processing time again to debug
react is much more simpler and that's
what makes it more popular in terms of
its simplicity and speed as compared to
other frameworks like angular what is
the difference between es5 and es6
standard so these are scripting
standards okay that are defined by the
european computer manufacturers
association or ecma and all of the
scripting languages are a subset of the
standard and are derived from these
standards to ensure that the code will
execute on all browsers and the code
that we are writing is standards based
so these are the few instances where es6
syntax has changed from es5 if you look
at the es5 first syntax at the top we're
creating a simple react class component
and the render function just returns a
stream of html content in ex6 there's a
new keyword that comes in which is
extends so you are extending from the
base react component and creating a
custom component and then returning a
stream of characters also the function
keyword no longer needs to be used so
the exports versus export also changes
so you use exports to export out class
from a module so that it can be accessed
from another module in es6 you simply
say export and the component require
versus import so you would require a
third-party component or an api into
your javascript file to use it in es6
it's replaced with the import statement
very similar to the syntax that we use
in code java so how do you go and create
a react app first you install node.js as
a base platform which you can download
from the node.js website next any text
editor of your choice could be atom
visual studio code or sublime text third
you create a react app using a command
prompt terminal depending on the os you
are using the command to give is create
hyphen react space my first app okay so
the command that you would give to
create a new react app is create hyphen
react hyphen app space and the name of
the application you would want to create
in this case it is my hyphen first
hyphen app and that could be a custom
name of your choice so what is an event
in react well on the web when you talk
about dynamic html it's all about
interacting with the user so the user
performs some interaction event with the
web page which could be a click of a
button a mouse move and these events in
action uh can be triggered by a user or
any system or could be pressing a key or
a mouse click etc and in response to
that event you would execute a block of
code which is called an event handler so
here we have class simple which is a
custom class that extends the base react
component the name of the function work
which triggers a simple alert message
box and a render function which returns
html when you click on the button we
would want to bind that to the event
handler this dot work and that's how you
connect a click event to an event
handler function what are synthetic
events in react well a synthetic event
is an object which acts as a cross
browser wrapper around the browser's
native event it combines the behavior of
different browsers native events into
one api which makes sure that the events
are consistent across different browsers
and this brings in the standard space
development to ensure in this digital
age the code that we are creating for
different browsers have consistency in
terms of its execution so here we see a
function action link we see a function
handle click which takes e as an event
parameter e dot prevent default ensures
that there is no error that the browser
is raising in case the event function
call is not directly compatible with
that specific browser so prevent default
is used to suppress any browser specific
errors or crashes and a simple
console.lock which will lock into the
developer tools window which says you
just clicked a link and then we've got
the return where we are returning the
view to or the html template where on
click we connect to this event handler
called handle click so handle click is
basically a wrapper and the entire
action link is
a wrapper object which is a synthetic
event we don't directly go and bind to
the on click and then associate a
function with it we actually associate a
synthetic object with it which binds the
base default event that could be
specific to a browser so some browsers
would probably understand an on click
sun another browser would understand a
click and to ensure that its consistency
of syntax and from a development
perspective the code that we write will
run on all browsers we need to take care
of using the synthetic events which
isolate the developer out from the
complexity of writing code specific to
different browsers so you just write
generic code which will work on
different browsers so how do lists work
in react so the list display data in an
ordered format the traversal of lists is
done using the map function so here we
see there is a function called list of
names which takes a variable props as a
parameter props dot names will allow us
to get a reference to all of the array
of names that are passed constant list
names is another variable created equal
to name start map and
we are using the arrow operator which is
now an ecmascript standard and
again we are using the opening tag of
the li html element the key is equal to
the name attribute so the brace bracket
will bind that to the name attribute
then we just print the name itself and
we close the ally tag so that's the
names.map function and finally we return
in an unordered list the list names
themselves so the map function will run
through and iterate over the list of
names list them in the li tag the li tag
will get injected into the unordered
list and will finally get returned out
as a stream of html elements in the next
code snippet below we create a constant
variable names we are associating it
with a set of five names and we simply
say render list of names names equal to
names the moment we do that
we are using list of names as a custom
html element which is not system defined
it starts looking for the function list
of names passes the names added to it
iterates over it using the map function
which is an inbuilt react function
brings out all of the lists it's very
similar to a forward loop that you would
write for iteration in other programming
languages and then finally what you get
returned in the get element by id app is
nothing but a list of simple names
wrapped in a li element that are printed
on the view so why is there a need of
using keys in lists so keys are very
important in the code snippet that we
saw due to the following reasons the
first reason the key is a unique
identifier if you would want to search
for a name in the list it is used to
identify which items have changed
updated or deleted from the list so if
you want to perform cloud operations on
the data you would want to search for
which element do you want to update or
delete or change it also helps to
determine which components need to be
re-rendered instead of re-rendering all
the components every time and it
increases performance as only the
changed components have to be
re-rendered and not all the components
on the page what are forms in react so
using forms users can interact with the
application and enter required
information whenever needed so forms can
contain certain elements such as text
fields buttons checkboxes radio buttons
etc and forms are also used for many
different tasks such as user
authentication searching filtering etc
how do you create a form pretty simple
again create a custom component called
name from that will extend
react.component we create a state
variable this.state is equal to value we
handle the change by writing a handle
change event and we handle the submit by
writing a handle submit event in the
change event we just change the state by
saying set state of the value to
event.target.value event being a system
defined keyword passed as a parameter
and in the submit we simply alert that a
certain name was entered and we trap the
value that was entered into the form
prevent default to suppress the browser
from raising any errors on the render
function we return a form on the submit
we connect to the handle submit event
and we bind the data submitted from the
form to the handle submit event and we
pass the this pointer which is a
reference to the current context of the
view itself we open a label specify the
name we then specified input box as text
the value is set to this dot state dot
value and on change we simply connect to
the handle change event and bind to it
and pass the context of the text box
itself so the moment we change the value
in the text box as we are typing the
handle change event will receive the
updated value and set the state and when
we click on the submit button the handle
submit event handler executes and we
alert out the current value printed in
the text box and that's it so how do you
write comments in react when you're a
developer if you want to comment out
some code or if you want to set comments
to enhance the maintainability of the
code a single line comment is as simple
as given in most other programming
languages backslash astrid to open
astrix to close multi-line commands
follow the same syntax and can span
multiple slides to add comments to
functions in terms of what the function
can do and what are the types that it
can return what is the arrow function
and how is it used so an arrow function
is a shorter way of writing a function
in react if you look at the snippet on
the top my input on change equal to we
are connecting to this dot handle change
dot bind and that's the longer version
of how you can connect it to an event
handler the shorter version is on change
equal to e arrow operator this dot
handle on change so you don't need to
call the bind explicitly you can replace
that with the arrow operator and reduce
the amount of code that you typically
write how is react different from react
native so react and react native are
completely different react was released
in 2013 it's a web-based platform it is
html compliant it generates html views
it uses css for styling and it's based
on javascript html and css react native
on the other hand is targeted to
mobility devices it's meant to create
installable apps on android and ios
released in 2015 not based on html and
css and it basically requires the
react.js api to create these installable
apps for these mobility ecosystems how
is react different from angular another
popular framework by google so angular
created by google completely based on
the model view controller pattern works
on the real dom layer and requires a
full tree shake at the tom layer to
update views and components supports
bi-directional data mining the rendering
is purely done on the client side the
performance comparatively slow react.js
on the other hand created by facebook
it's the view layer of the model view
controller pattern it works at the
virtual dom layer and it sends faster
it's unidirectional data binding and not
two-way and the rendering is typically
what is done at the server side and what
you get is a response on the client as a
stream of html characters as an output
let's talk about and discuss some
questions around react components so
what are components in react so these
are the building blocks you can think of
them as lego blocks so you break your
problem down into small parts each part
identifying a certain solution of the
problem which is what we define as a
component so they are building blocks of
a react application and a single app
usually consists of multiple components
so it splits the ui into independent
reusable pieces that can be processed
separately a component is essentially a
piece of the user interface or the html
view what is the use of render method in
react so it is compulsory for each
component to have a render method if not
there wouldn't be any html for the
component to render on your view so the
render function returns the html which
is to be displayed within a component
like you see on the screen there is a
class app that extends the react
component and it returns a simple h1
element called hello simply learn and of
course do remember to export the app out
so that it can be accessed from other
components as well if you need to render
more than one element all the elements
must be inside a single parent tag like
a div or a form what is state in react
the state of a component is an object
that holds some data within it the data
would influence the output of the
component now how do you implement state
in react so state holds the data that a
component renders on the web application
for example here we have created in the
constructor this dot state equal to and
this temporary anonymous object has two
attributes car and pi when we return we
simply return this dot state dot car and
this dot state dot by now this is how
you would create stateful components and
access the state properties within the
view how do you update the state of a
component by using the built-in set
state method you can go ahead and update
the state of the component so here we
have a simple render function that
returns the state itself state dot
message and on the on click connects to
a button press function the moment you
click on the button the button press
function sets the state to another
message so the initial message in the
constructor is welcome to simply learn
the moment you click on the button the
set state triggers and changes it to
best place to learn so the data on the
view would be updated what are props in
react well props is just a short form
for properties and that is what allows
us to pass arguments or data to a
component props are passed to components
in the way similar to that of attributes
that are passed to an html element so
how do you pass props between two
components so let's say we have an
app.js component on the top and a
main.js component at the bottom at the
top we are trying to return this dot
props dot car and the pike so two car
and bike attributes associated with this
props of the app component in the main
component when you look at the render
function we are associating car prop
equal to a value of 1 600 cc and bike
prop equal to value of
150cc and to access it if you look at
the import statement we are importing
app from
app.jsx and this is how you can
cross-access properties from one
component within the other so what are
the difference between state and props
well state holds information about the
components they are mutable they can be
changed they cannot be accessed by child
components and they cannot have state
props allow to pass data from one
component to the other as an argument
they are immutable they are read only
and props can be accessed by the child
component and they can have props as
well what is a higher order component in
react so these act as a container for
other components which helps in keeping
components simple and induces the
reusability factor they are generally
used when a common logic has to be used
by multiple components that's when you
group together a set of components
within a higher order component in react
how can you embed two or more components
into one this code snippet demonstrates
the app component which returns a hello
text and it has a custom tag called
simple the simple tag is defined in the
component below and it returns text
called simply learn and in the render of
the react dom
we simply go and render the app
component so hello simply learn would be
the final output and that's how you can
embed one component into the other using
this methodology what are the
differences between class and functional
components so stateful components would
extend react component in this case and
if you could look at the render it
simply renders this dot props dot title
the constant stateless component would
be equal to props the div tag returns
this dot props dot title so you can look
at the style very different in terms of
class and functional components one
using the arrow operator one using the
traditional class and render method so
the class component can hold or manage
state complex as compared to stateless
components can work all of the life
cycle methods of the component and it
can be reused the functional component
cannot hold a managed state they are
simple and easy to understand it does
not work with any lifecycle method and
it cannot be reused let's explain the
lifecycle methods of components we've
got kenich initial state which is
executed before the creation of the
component component did mount which is
executed when the component gets
rendered and placed on the dom should
component update which is invoked when a
component decides any changes to the dom
and returns true or false value based on
certain conditions component did update
it is invoked immediately after the
rendering takes place component will
unmount which is invoked immediately
before a component is destroyed and
unmounted permanently let's move to the
react redux set of questions so what is
redux it's an open source javascript
library used to manage application state
and react uses redux for building the
user interface what are components of
redux the first is the store which holds
the state of the application store
contains state which defines the user
interface which triggers a set of
actions which are then sent to the
reducer so store holds the state action
is the source information for the store
and reducer specifies how the
application state changes in response to
actions sent to the store what is flux
well flux is the application
architecture that facebook uses for
building web applications and it works
in this way the action is triggered
which is sent to the dispatcher the
dispatcher sends it to the store the
store sends it to the view and the view
sends it back to the action and that's
exactly how the steps would continue in
sequence so when we trigger an action
the dispatcher will get notified once
the dispatcher has dealt with an action
the stores listening to it will get
triggered the view gets updated when the
state of the store changes user action
at the view is sent to the dispatcher to
then be processed how is redux different
from flux redux is an open source
javascript library used to manage
application state the store state is
immutable it can only have a single
store and it uses the concept of reducer
flux on the other hand is an
architecture and not a framework or
library the store state is mutable it
can have multiple stores and it uses the
concept of dispatcher let's look at some
react router questions what is a react
router a rear router is a package which
is used to create routing in a react
application react router is used for
developing single page web applications
it allows multiple views in a single
application by defining multiple routes
in that react application how is react
routing different from conventional
routing react routing has a single html
page it uses or the end user rather
would navigate multiple views within the
same file called a single page app the
page does not refresh since it's a
single page file and there is improved
performance since you are not navigating
across multiple pages conventional
routing each view is a separate html
file the user would navigate multiple
files for each view the page would
refresh every time the user navigates
which would hence result in slower
performance how do you implement react
routing you can implement react routing
using a very simple method considering
the above components let's say you've
got a component called app about and
contact so here you can specify the
route path if the route part is just
slash the route defaults out it takes
you to the app component if the route is
slash about in the url given by the end
user you automatically navigate and
activate and load the about component
and if the url is slash contact it would
take you to the contact component let's
talk about react styling questions how
do you style react components either you
use inline styling by using simple css
by simply saying color blue and that's
going to be the output of the h1 element
or i could use a javascript object by
specifying a constant simple style
object and specifying a keypair value of
color background color margin font
family and apply that object as the
style parameter which would result in
this styled output how do you style
react components using a css style sheet
so here's an external style sheet so
we've written all the styling rules in a
separate css file app.css we've imported
that at the top of the app.js react
class and lo and behold you have the
output simplified as generated on your
page let's explain the use of css
modules in react so a css module file is
created.module.css is the extension the
css inside a module file is available
only for the component that is importing
it so there are no naming conflicts so
dot button is the css styling inside
button.module.css
and that is what we've imported from in
the app.js file so when you view the
button style start button is the styling
picked up from the
button.module.css file all right so that
is it for this complete react crash
course if you like the video give it a
thumbs up and hit the subscribe button
and the bell icons to never miss an
update
thank you for being here keep learning
and stay tuned to simply learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you